All right, chat, we're waiting for the lobby code, which we just got.
Now we're not waiting for it anymore.
We got the code.
The code's up.
Like just in time.
Oh my God.
Sorry, chat.
My YouTube was bugging out and it wouldn't let me stream for like 20 years.
I sound dead inside just because I'm sick.
Unlucky is also sick.
So we are counting on Effect to carry both of us.
Yes, sir.
Yep.
And if he doesn't...
Too many excuses.
We didn't even start playing.
And if he doesn't carry us, we're going to...
Unlucky's going to go to where he lives and burn his MVP medal.
Hold on, what?
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
We didn't talk about that one.
Well, we did.
We were like, if he doesn't carry, we're going to take away his MVP if he doesn't carry.
What about a burning medal?
A burning part.
Oh, you're not going to burn it?
Okay, you're right.
We should sell it.
You're right.
There's more money to selling it.
Unlucky's going to go to where he lives and then take his MVP medal and sell it.
That's crazy.
That's called life, Unlucky.
Oh, damn.
All right.
He's got to learn.
I love stealing anyways.
It's not stealing.
It's called revoking.
Yes.
Welcome, Effect, and Unlucky.
For those who don't know who they are, they are part of Alliance, which is who won the world champions for esports, for Apex Legends.
And they are, yeah, they're gamer gamers.
And now they're here to win $100.
Let's go.
To try.
To try to win $100.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
That'd be a good try.
All right.
Anyway, none of them are the IGLs of Alliance and I'm not an IGL either.
So who's IGLing for this team?
I'm going to be like duo doing this.
Duo, duo thing, you know?
Oh, a duo GL?
Yeah.
Okay.
I believe in you guys.
Because I don't believe in me, so I have to believe in you guys.
I'm pushing through this sickness right now.
I'm trying my best to like not die inside.
I'll send you.
I'm blind, bro.
You got it?
Yeah, I found it.
Yo, what are we playing right now?
Oh yeah, what are we playing?
That is such a good question.
Is there anything banned or something?
No, no, we can play whatever comp we want.
Yeah.
What do you like to play?
What Legends?
I can play anything but Valk.
I hate Valk.
Okay.
Uh...
Shit.
Let's play Bang...
Bang Path.
What do you want to play?
Bang Path?
Yeah, I guess I'm buying you Path.
And then you can play whatever you want.
Oh, I can play whatever.
But what is whatever?
What's the most ideal with being in Path?
Guys!
How many years do you have in Apex Legends, guys?
Two days.
I don't know.
I'm new to this game, guys.
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, you can play whatever you want.
You can...
Whatever you want.
You can switch up a little bit every game if you want.
No, I don't want free will.
I...
We go random Legends every game.
Oh my God.
Random Legends every...
What's the most ideal?
We close our eyes and then we just go with the mouse.
Okay, all right.
I swear, we lose our first game because we...
I swear to God.
We lose our first game because I was on Valk because I closed my eyes.
I swear.
I swear to God.
That's fine.
Okay, we're going to do Mystery Heroes.
All right.
Put it on the wheel.
We'll see what I get.
Oh, wait.
I could try...
Is it Newcastle meta?
Yeah.
You want to play Newcastle?
Yeah, I can play Newcastle.
All right.
Sure.
Okay.
I can do it.
Guys, I'm not doing random fucking Mystery Heroes, guys.
I'm not.
That's, like, a chance that I would accidentally pick Valkyrie, and I don't want that to happen.
It's fine.
I literally have, like, two games on Valk in my entire life on eBay.
I don't want to play Valk.
It's okay.
Keep it for last game.
That's true.
And we'll keep it for last game.
We're still not here.
They said 12-10 was a mandatory start.
They shouldn't...
They...
Shaking my head.
They should have started instantly.
Oh, my God.
What's the point of fucking deadlines if they're not even gonna start it?
Exactly, right?
Yeah.
I mean...
Humans.
Can't believe it.
Not even gonna...
Not even gonna listen to their own rules.
Shake my head.
Yeah, bro.
Also, guys, they're really tired because they're from EU.
So...
So, that's why they sound dead inside, just like...
I'm just dead inside because I'm sick.
Yeah, I feel like I would be not tired if I wasn't sick, to be honest.
True.
I think I'll be fine at 9 PM.
Yeah, they just got back from Japan.
So, I don't know why Unlucky...
In fact, didn't get sick, but Unlucky did.
Oh, man.
I don't know.
I don't...
What did Unlucky do?
Hmm.
Oh, yeah.
I just...
You know?
Like...
Yeah?
Yeah.
I don't know.
No, but to be honest, bro.
You know there's so many people off the lines and all that stuff for their child to get sick, but I didn't really get sick.
He just has a stronger immune system.
I guess.
He's just Eastern European.
So, he's more...
I think...
He's built different.
Maybe.
I always get sick.
As soon as I leave my house, I'm sick.
Yeah, your immune system fucking sucks.
Not bad.
Not shit.
Bro, you gotta let...
You gotta let...
You have to go outside more so your immune system builds up a more tougher resilience against the weather.
Yeah.
I'm not that guy.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
You're Apex, bro.
Yeah.
You have to stay inside.
I don't do outside.
Yeah.
It's true.
We're all terminally online.
Outside is too neat.
Yeah.
That's true.
What?
Where did we get at for?
Running five minutes behind.
Oh, okay.
So, we're gonna start at 12.15 then.
Yeah.
Okay.
What the fuck?
That's gone.
Oh, my God.
15 minutes late.
That's a lot.
This tournament.
After three minutes...
Three games, it's gonna be like 30 minutes.
What?
30-minute transition after three games to shout out the sponsors.
I can literally shout out the sponsors for them in fucking two minutes right now, but I won't because I'm not sponsored.
They don't get free shit from me.
They don't.
I don't understand why it's 30 minutes.
I don't understand.
It can be done in 10 to 15 minutes at best.
God.
Yeah.
That's a long ass time.
It's a long ass time.
What are we gonna do in 30 minutes?
Okay.
We're gonna just relax for 30 minutes and...
What the fuck are these team names?
A quick nap.
A quick 30-minute nap, and then they never come back, so I have to play alone.
The last three minutes, I'm just on my own team.
Shit.
What the fuck is...
What the fuck is going on in the chat?
Our name is going to LAN.
If we win, we're going to LAN.
Yeah, we're going to LAN, guys.
Yeah, guys.
I don't know if you guys heard, but I'll be...
I'm signing up to Alliance.
That was my announcement.
I'll be Alliance's coach.
True, bro.
That's why Hakis isn't here.
Yup.
Yeah, man.
Our manager told us that we're getting dropped, and me and Unlucky are going to Japan.
Yeah, Hakis is getting dropped.
Me and Unlucky, in fact, are going to go to LAN from third place.
It's the 20th place right there.
Hakis who?
You're right.
Who?
Guys, we needed fresh new blood.
Huh?
New blood in the team Alliance.
I really...
Bro, Hakis is too old.
I didn't say that.
I...
You said new blood.
That's basically the same thing.
It could be anybody.
Yeah?
Yeah.
All right.
Who's the second oldest?
Unlucky.
He's like three months older than me.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah.
He's such a boomer.
Damn.
Three months older?
That's practically three fucking years.
God damn.
You might as well retire.
Oh, okay.
What the hell?
Oh, no.
No, yeah.
When you hit that big 2-0.
Oh, man.
That's...
It's...
It's soon.
It's soon enough.
Three months.
The big 2-0.
That's when you know.
It might be me.
Wow.
Getting old.
Don't worry.
I believe in us.
I don't.
Let's go.
What?
Why don't you believe anymore?
I'm shocked.
It's because his birthday is coming up.
So, now he stopped believing.
Yeah.
It's okay.
We all get old, guys.
Even though when you've turned 20, you still have a lot ahead of you.
I don't know about that one.
What?
Retirement angle.
What the fuck?
What?
You're not going to retire at 20?
I am.
You'll see.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Wait.
When are you turning 20?
Three months.
Oh, in three...
Okay, guys.
Let's have a countdown.
Let's...
Have a countdown.
Three months.
Like, one month before Japan, he just fucking... he's gone.
He disappears.
He goes off the grid.
We're winning champs and then I'm gone.
Yeah.
He's like, this is it.
And then off the grid.
No.
Stay in Japan.
Okay.
You're going to...
You're going to legally stay in Japan.
No.
It's going to be a...
Legal tourist there.
Oh my God.
This is the sick team.
It's okay.
Guys, for those who don't know, Effect and... both Effect and Unlucky are on rollers.
So like, even when sick, they play just as good as a mouse and keyboard player.
Okay.
What?
Yeah.
It's true.
Okay.
Just when you're sick, when you're not sick, you play even better than the MNK players.
That's how it goes.
Yeah.
Ugh.
I can't breathe.
It's okay.
Me too.
I have like a tissue box right next to me.
Ew.
But you're MNK and also sick.
Yes.
So I play just as bad as everybody else, but it's okay.
We're here to have fun and not be last place.
Yeah, we are.
Where are we landing by the way?
Shipyard.
Oh my gosh.
Good question.
Shit.
Where even is that?
It's at the bottom.
Shipyard Arcade.
It's at the very bottom.
Okay.
I'll send you the map thingy.
Where?
Okay.
This is where our first landing spot is.
And then our second one is Devastated Coast.
Devastated Coast?
Yeah.
We literally got 19th pick for drops.
So I was like, I don't care.
Just roll.
It's not that bad.
It's okay.
I was like, just roll for it.
Like, I don't fucking care.
We have two shitty drops left.
Okay.
Please not be first pick because I don't know where Newcastle is.
There he is.
Okay.
Here we go.
First game.
First game on.
Going to be so much fun, guys.
Yeah.
Bye.
I can feel the hype from the fact he's like...
Let's go, baby.
Let's go.
Where's the hype?
I'm locked.
He's just locked in.
Look at that.
Look at our beautiful bat.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he got the code.
It's real.
It's real?
Let's go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm going to go left.
I'm going to go loot here, okay?
Let's not loot here.
How do I loot this place?
How do I even loot this area?
I'll loot the middle, I guess.
I'll loot the middle.
Yeah.
I'm just so confused looking at this.
I see.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
This is an East Coast server.
That's good for you guys.
180 ping.
Oh.
Yeah.
180 ping.
Let's go, free.
That's best.
No.
This is better than 200!
Okay, the door just closed again after I opened it.
Oh my god, I'm a fucking mess.
I'm like, not looting properly.
It's okay.
First game on.
First game, yeah yeah, first game warm up.
I agree.
I have flatline and eva 8.
Yeah, the zone is closed.
That's the thing.
Nice.
I believe.
Alright guys, where is end zone?
No idea.
Oh.
Give a lucky guess.
With all your experience.
All the way back there?
Okay.
Also guys, what do I get?
Swift shield or thick shield?
I think thick shield.
I think so too.
Which one?
Thick.
Thick?
Okay.
Yeah yeah.
Okay, thick shield.
I need a second Mozambique.
Oh, I got one for you.
You can have mine.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll give the roller player the second Mozamb.
Very nice.
Very nice of you.
Yeah.
Oh, I already found another one anyway.
It's a massive I think.
Okay, I'm on my way.
I'm going to get the beak and I'm going to scan.
Alright.
Beacon.
Where's the knockdown shield?
Oh, there it is.
I'll use that.
Oh.
I'm scanning.
I'm being quick.
It's a lock brush.
Oh my god, you guys got it correct.
More like a him, him, him correct.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
It's called being three months younger.
I'm going to do it.
It's still pretty good.
Yeah.
It's his reflexes.
His intuition is still prime.
Oh my god.
We got no UV.
Actually, I just thought about it.
I already got...
People are already fighting?
Damn.
There might be a team still here.
Yeah.
We gotta watch out.
I don't know how fast they're looting.
It's okay.
So, yeah.
You guys are in front of me.
So, I believe...
Oh.
I'll need that.
I only got one bat.
I can give you...
Oh.
I can give you one too.
Yeah.
I can give you one.
Here.
I have three as well.
Let's keep going.
Ah.
My eyes.
My eyes are burning.
I love hearing that your eyes are burning.
Oh my god.
My...
My hope in us gets higher.
Whoa.
I don't have long range.
We can just go left.
And take that bin too.
Alright.
But I've never been there.
On the left.
I haven't...
I didn't...
You guys have never been to the left side before?
Nope.
The ballooning.
We can shoot it.
Do we shoot it?
Yeah.
The people on it.
I'll shoot it with my little bolt.
That balloon was deeper than I actually thought it was.
What the fuck?
Alright.
What's in that little...
Do you want to play for a zone here or no?
Maybe I should try to get in.
Miron.
Do you want to play for a beacon?
We can go there.
They go there bro.
There goes Point Kill.
Alright.
Calm.
Is there any balloon here?
Well, there's a helmet here.
I'll take that.
I think there is actually.
I believe in your IGL...
Dual GLs.
I listen.
That's wrong.
Ugh.
I shouldn't believe that.
It's going to go miserable.
Okay.
Look.
Like we're obviously not going to listen to me.
I have at least to explain it.
What do I do if my...
Both my dual GLs are a rock?
I'm crying.
Fucking choc die.
I really want this cash there actually.
I need like more energy.
Oh there it is.
I need more energy.
If you guys see nemesis let me know because I don't have a long range.
We're good by the way.
I don't see anything.
Okay.
Oh I'm by myself.
I feel scared.
Me too.
It's so quiet.
It really is.
It's all by ourselves.
I got that quick?
Oh my god.
Let's go back.
Alright.
We might as well take that bin too.
Should we flee the bin that's not taken?
Maybe yeah.
Actually yeah.
Behind us.
Behind us?
No I was just looking.
Oh okay.
Oh my god don't... saying that made me scared.
It's fine.
I'm sorry.
I'm super skittish.
It's good.
People... oh!
People to our right.
There's so many stars.
I love... I hate this map.
We could have been playing on World's Edge guys.
Hahaha.
Oh it's the probably.
Woah.
Shit.
Fuck I almost cracked.
Smoke out.
Yeah yeah.
No signal.
The long way right.
The shield is slowly moving.
We can go here.
Oh nice nemesis.
I'm on guys far right.
Yeah we can get inside.
Yeah yeah I'm inside.
Nice.
I got my nemesis right here.
Use your dab.
Yeah yeah.
Give me my shield.
Heh.
Wanna play this building or the other one?
Um.
I think this one.
There's a golden bolt in that bin.
Okay.
I'm gonna go.
I just have four cells.
I dropped my own.
Oh I can give you some cells here.
So what's the team though right?
That's.
Oh wait there's two cells literally right here.
Hahaha.
Haha.
That's a Valk team there.
Huh.
Okay what do I.
Did I get stronghold or miracle worker?
Sponsoon is building in front of us I think.
What did you say?
Miracle worker or stronghold?
I think.
The one where it's like energized.
I don't know how it's called.
Energized.
Okay I got it.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Stronghold.
Yeah.
That's good.
Okay stay here for now.
I'm gonna go.
I mean we can hold off.
Both?
Okay I'll stay here then.
Team flying.
I think we should watch our back.
Okay.
Team flight.
That's fine.
We're gonna land up here somewhere.
Yeah yeah.
I'm gonna try to hold our back a little bit as well at the same time.
Okay I'll look in front of us then.
God they have such high high ground.
Oh there's a team inside this house.
Yeah.
Pretty much everyone.
Everywhere.
Okay I'm just gonna play stairs and hold back until it's closing.
Okay.
Sorry I'm on actual mistake on- oh it's not on.
Oh yeah non-miss mode isn't on.
Yeah it's fine.
That's fine.
We don't care.
Okay.
It's okay.
Alright guys this is the best part about competitive guys we do nothing.
We're like two zones.
Love it.
We literally just hang out cause there's 200 buildings here.
Yup.
So nothing dies.
I love Apex.
Yup.
We love Apex.
Guys don't worry in the last zone that's when things start colliding.
I love Apex.
Yep.
I think I got him really quick.
Can I pick him up now real quick.
Oh I should die on him.
Hopefully I will cobble the end game.
I can't wait.
Oh somebody has a Sheela.
Hm.
Wait that's a Sheela or a Vantage?
I can't tell.
Yeah it's Sheela.
Okay.
It could be both.
I'm thinking I'll play Vantage.
Someone in my chat is like unlucky is so handsome.
How- you don't- I'm not- you're not even watching his stream.
You're watching..
How would you know?
What the hell?
It's down to the last one.
You messed up.
His name is Keanu Weebs.
He's literally a fucking icon on my screen, like how can he be?
He's like, there's this guy looking at me.
Yo, what if I hit your ring console dude?
Yeah bro, go for it.
You gonna hit it?
Yeah, I'll smoke you, don't worry.
Okay.
I don't want to shoot too much, because I have limited ammo.
You don't have to have triple armor, it's fine.
Yeah, we're fine.
They're playing out here bro, they're not even holding the building.
We could literally zip on top and fuck them up.
Can we actually?
I don't know how many people have angles on this.
Yeah, we don't have angles.
I'm like, are you sure?
Yeah, I'm like, are you sure?
Okay, they're...
We're not in zone though.
Can we just take a floor now?
Take a floor?
Okay.
Which side, the frame yours?
I think it's your side better, no?
It's the balcony side.
Is this?
Oh, it's this, okay.
Just play up, go baby.
Going, going, going, going.
Bangalore, rampart.
Oh, they walled it up.
We can see proof.
Let's see proof.
Yeah, come, come, come, come, come.
Here I am.
I'm gonna come up though, right now.
Wall cracked.
I'm going here.
Serious, serious, serious.
Oh shit, okay.
Goodbye.
Oh shit, I didn't realize we were committing.
Sorry, that was my bad.
I didn't know we were committing, I'm sorry.
I didn't hear the commit.
You can just craft maybe.
Okay.
Yeah, you can go out, yeah.
That was my bad, I didn't realize you were committing to it.
I mean, don't worry, I committed first, I didn't know I'm not getting followed, right?
Yeah.
I don't think I can, you can try to craft here but...
Yeah, I can craft, you guys.
I think.
I'm gonna craft.
Easy, doable.
Where's the crafter?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
I hear people next to me.
I'm a little scared.
I'm scared.
Yeah, I think you're getting chased.
Yeah, you chased me.
Yeah, you chased me, yeah.
Ah.
Beam up.
Jesus Christ.
Run.
No!
Oh!
That is you!
I...
Oh my god.
That's fine.
That was my bad.
I didn't hear...
I didn't hear you were gonna commit to it, in fact.
Excuse me?
I didn't hear it, sorry.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I'm gonna raise...
I'm lucky to lock in.
That's great.
I thought you were gonna peek stairs with me, bro.
She was leading one.
I was botting.
Oh, you got cracked when we go?
I went up the roof?
Yeah.
See, I'm gonna raise your volume, guys, a little higher.
Guys, it's the sick debuff, guys.
It's the sick...
Yeah, I feel like I'm getting sick, too, bro.
Just letting me sit with you.
It's really the sick debuff right now.
You kidding me?
He's sickness.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, it's shocked out here.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Warm up.
It's the warm up round.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is the first game.
It's coming.
Bro, let's just push people.
Yeah, we can.
What do you think of that?
Yeah, let's do it.
Second game, we just push people.
Yeah.
Play Rev?
You're gonna play Rev?
Oh my god.
That Valkyr's died.
Shit.
He just died.
Holy shit.
I don't even know how he died.
Did I die to his teammates?
You died to enemy.
Not even.
I...
I died to Hazel, internet girl, in Ipt.
I saw you got shot by enemy, so I thought that's what happened.
I don't know.
You know, we could've fucking...
We probably should've zipped up and put walls.
Newcastle walls.
Yeah.
Reset and then fucking slide into the plant thing.
That would've been perfect.
Ah, man.
Too much thinking, Tor.
What's the rest of the game?
Yeah, it was more like standard angle, you know?
Yeah, we just...
I went up the fucking thingy, I saw you shot the gun, zip, and then I heard a guy under us on the stairs, I was like, yeah, I'm gonna surprise him.
I gave him like one...
He was literally one shot, by the way.
The Rambo was literally one shot.
Ah, that's unlucky.
Yeah, I told you guys a lot too.
So unlucky for unlucky.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, lucky for me.
First game was shut down.
Just a warm up.
Second game, we know how people play now.
Just gonna int everyone.
It's fine.
Okay.
Wait, are we gonna...
So, should I still play Newcastle or should I play something else?
We're gonna int everybody.
What are you...
Thinking.
What do you wanna play?
Like, do you wanna play still bang or...
Mmm...
Play FRAF, actually.
Nothing else on bang.
Okay.
Hmm, half point Gibby.
Ah.
No.
Wait, so what do I play?
I'm thinking red, though.
Don't wanna poke bout, so...
Ahem.
But Newcastle is still fine, I think.
Newcastle is still fine?
Okay, I'll keep playing Newcastle.
I think it's still fine.
Yeah, guys.
It's just very lucky that this entire team is practically safe.
We made Effect sick as well.
We gave him the sickness.
We're all sad.
Alright.
No!
We couldn't live till end, so now we have to watch this.
Yup.
Alright guys, this is motivation.
We can't fuck up next game, so we don't have to watch people for 15 minutes.
It's the worst part because it's still early game.
So we have to wait so long.
We have to wait so long.
Literally sick plays.
Oh, he's dead.
Unless...
He's still dead.
Why isn't this in a corner?
It's calm though.
Are you able to play pubs in between?
No, it's not ideal to play pubs in between right now.
Cause...
Not really.
Yeah, not now.
We could, but...
Yeah...
Their warm up is killing real players in this lobby.
Yeah.
Alright guys.
That's why we're gonna play different next game.
Yeah, yeah.
We know we're not a zone team now, so we'll play edge.
Yeah, I'll go with the...
UVA.
I mean, like, the people...
Bro, I'm gonna play Meggy.
You're gonna play...
You sure?
Yeah.
We could try, we can... What the fuck?
What the fuck?
I mean, it's literally one guy.
I mean...
Oh my god.
They died so fast.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
What a shield.
Yup.
Yeah, we're gonna be playing aggressive next game.
Cause we're not...
We're not a zone team.
Like, we realized in that first game, we're like...
Oh yeah, we're...
We can't play zone.
We need warm up a little bit.
Yeah, they need...
They need warm up to get into the kill mode.
I just need a...
I just need to not be sick.
Nothing's gonna change with me.
It's okay.
Oh my god, he went off the grid!
Wait, huh?
He can't steal it cause someone is resing.
Oh my god.
Wait, they got the res though.
Go off the grid!
They won't know!
They'll think it's one person.
Oh!
Okay, that...
That's... oh... I think...
Oh...
Dragon...
Dragon died to zone?
No way.
Guys, relax.
People were like...
Guys, people were criticizing my team for being too strong.
But like, this team is like...
Too strong too.
Come on.
One is a fucking coach.
Two are also pro players.
Like...
I'm sick.
Unlucky sick.
Like, we're practically...
We're playing nerfed out here.
Yeah, we're playing nerfed as hard.
It's been a rough day.
Yeah, it's been a rough fucking week.
It's been a...
Shit, what the fuck is going up there?
Lots of things.
I would love to play Valak, but it's high ping and Valak is like kinda shit on high ping.
It's high ping and Valak is like kinda shit on high ping.
That's true.
180 ping.
Yeah.
Cause you know, we're 7.
Maybe we can play Valak.
Valak, Rampart, something else.
Jesus Christ.
Ah, dragon.
It's alright, he's alive.
This is what...
This is what Vektor's gonna do, but even better.
Cause he won't die like that.
Yeah, they're dead.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is happening to the enemy, dude?
I was like, what the fuck is going on?
Holy shit.
Oh, that's...
Oh, okay, goodbye.
We're jumping a lot.
I couldn't even see what was going on.
He was taking damage.
Yeah.
Oh man.
Alright.
Wing Flavors.
Wingaria and Wing Beano just won.
What the...
Is this their names, actually?
No, no, it's like...
It's their nicknames.
Okay.
Ah, we go again.
You wanna play Mega now?
Yeah.
Let's kill everyone.
Just get all kill points.
It doesn't matter what placement we are.
As long as we get every kill point possible.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's basically it.
Alright.
We got this.
Who the fuck is KiviriSigmas?
Who the fuck is what?
It's KiviriSigmas.
KiviriSigmas.
15.
Team 15.
That's them.
Is that who killed us?
No.
I realized, by the way, last game, I died to a whole different team.
Oh, you got shot.
You must have got shot by a different team in the back.
Yeah.
That was in the other house.
I was... because when we started watching enemy in them.
Yeah.
Dragon was enemy's teammate and he hit me for 30.
And then I had two other completely different people on my kill feed.
Oh, that's...
So I died to a whole different team.
Yeah, you died to a different team.
Yeah.
Oh no, I died so fast.
The reaper never shot me.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah.
Yeah, because of the team in the other building.
It's okay.
Now we know our strats.
I just don't know the map that much.
Like, I didn't know I was so open in my back.
Like, it's just...
That's what I'm saying!
We could have had World's Edge!
Really, right?
I agree.
World's Edge is so much better.
Yeah!
See, now!
Now you agree!
Fucking this map sucks!
Okay, I need to get water.
I'll be back.
Yeah.
And I'm back.
So what's our team comp exactly?
Maggie, Newcastle, Pathfinder.
Wait, Newcastle what?
Maggie.
Maggie, Pathfinder.
So now we have double the walls!
Yeah.
That's okay.
We're gonna get like three wins in a row, right guys?
Yes.
All the wins.
Alright, this is it.
This is where we're locked in.
Yep.
I believe.
Why doesn't it vote somewhere?
Board Game 1?
Oh, we can actually vote for that?
Wait, really?
Okay, let's Board Game 1.
Let's...
Do we want a Game 7?
Yeah!
Yeah, let's...
Fuck your game!
Well, it doesn't voice it, but like we just play an additional game.
So like technically their game doesn't matter.
I just voted yeah.
Wait, where can you vote?
Which channel?
It's restart request.
Yeah, it's in support.
It's uh...
I don't think we're supposed to all vote.
It's okay.
No, no, fuck these people.
Do an extra game so your game doesn't matter anymore.
That's fucking right.
We win the vote.
It's 25 to 18, so we win the vote.
Damn.
So we are...
The first game doesn't count?
No, it does, but like they play...
We have to play an extra game.
So technically it doesn't count.
Because if that means like more points in... Yep, that's six points.
That's six wins for us.
Yeah, that's six wins for us.
Yeah!
Okay.
We can do it.
I have like your audio boosted up now for my end, so like I can hear.
You know like when you're sick, so like you can't...
It's like...
It's harder.
It's for me right now.
Like everything is so much more quieter.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
You want me to unblock your ears?
Oh, yeah.
Whoa, whoa, what?
No, no, that's not...
What?
Oh, it's gonna be ASMR with Effect and Unlucky.
Effect helps.
No, that's not ASMR.
That's something you don't want to hear.
Yeah, he doesn't want to hear that.
Oh, that means you've heard his ASMR.
Why would...
He's gonna do loud audio like...
Like what?
No, no, no, don't do it.
Unlucky has so much experience with the ASMR.
I really do.
You want me to pull up my professional mic actually?
Oh, shit!
You have a professional ASMR mic?
No, I don't.
You know that costs like a thousand plus dollars.
Yeah, I'm gonna play with my nails and, you know, glasses and stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and then, like, get stuck on the ears.
What?
Put it on right now.
My chat wants to hear it.
Where do we go, though?
Which team do we push?
I will see.
We'll figure it out.
Alright.
What bro said.
Last bro said.
Boss.
Alright, take an ass.
Okay.
Yeah, comms bro, comms.
Yeah, yeah, where are the comms?
What do we do?
It's first game.
Yeah, yeah, this is our first game, guys.
First game.
Alright, micromanage.
Micro and macromanages.
Yeah, Effect, come on, man.
Yeah, Effect, come on.
The youngest should do it.
That's what I'm saying.
His potential is higher than mine.
Yeah, yeah, his potential is higher.
You're gonna be the new IGL when Hawkus retires.
Damn.
I'd love to see that one.
Come on.
Alright, let's see.
God, I don't know how to loot this area.
It's all so new to me.
I've never been here before.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's good for...
Damn.
I need...
That's not a Mozambique I've summoned.
I'll take it.
Bro, Milo just got it.
This POI is so good.
Yeah!
We got it by pure luck, too.
We rolled it.
Yeah.
Because I was like, I don't care.
Oh my god.
We got gashed.
Put the prize in the bag.
Okay.
I really need the enjimag and the bolt.
Enjimag.
Let's see.
Okay, I need another...
Oh, shit.
I need another...
Mozambique if anybody finds one.
Okay.
That was one in the...
Okay, that's a bit too far.
That would hurt.
There's a 3x here.
My ping guy can do Mozambique.
Oh, okay.
Alright, I'm good to go.
My Mozambique has...
Can you get the cash?
Yeah, I'm going for it.
Alright, scan the UV then.
Alright, I'm ready.
Yeah, scan the UV.
Are they coming, maybe?
Yeah, they are, I think.
Yeah, they are.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'mma zip here.
Alright, I'm waiting for your zip.
Here I am.
I'm peeking over in a second.
Wait.
Whoa.
We heard a zip.
I think they turned around.
You're scared.
Yeah, they are, they're like up there.
Do you want to run into them?
I have ball.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Alright, I'm right behind.
I'm a little bit slow.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Path 1 is back.
Nades.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
I'm coming up in a second.
I might be dead.
Cracked him, cracked him.
Slow.
Path 1, dead.
Last one, last one.
I'm backing up.
Here, I'm coming over.
Yep.
Nice.
Pull back, pull back, pull back.
I'm pulling back, I'm pulling back.
He's looking, he's looking, he's looking.
Yep.
Dead.
Nice.
Well played.
Yay!
Let's go, baby!
Look at that, we got kills!
Look at us go!
Oh my god, we're locked, we're locked, we're locked, we're locked.
We're locked, we're so locked, we're so locked.
Locked, locked, locked.
Alright, I'm finishing, I'm finishing.
Watch out for them.
Somebody else is coming.
I'm going to go to ult, and I'm going to hit the UV then.
In a second.
I have so many bots.
Do I need medkit?
Yeah, I do.
I have it in alt-excel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go back.
Alright,
I'll wait for you guys.
Alright, I'll wait for you guys.
Let's go.
Let's go over here.
Alright.
I'll just get the points on the edge.
I feel like all the good teams are playing zone.
I think.
Maybe.
Enemy's team was playing zone, Fun's team was playing zone.
Since they were there.
Maybe we won't bump into them.
Alright, you're edging, you're edging.
I love edging.
Damn.
Those are my specials.
I love edging.
What's your opinion effect on edging in Apex?
Ten out of ten.
In Apex, right?
Yeah, yeah, in Apex, right?
I knew you were talking about Apex.
Wait, I'm going to get the cash quick.
Okay.
Yeah, they're here.
They opened the bin.
Oh, okay.
Can I still get the cash quick or no?
Yeah, yeah, go for it.
Woooo.
I feel so vulnerable here.
Coming up.
This is Glapia.
Huh?
Bangalore, Puffy.
Shit, they fell down.
They have white armors.
Okay.
Yeah, they do.
I hit 70 on one.
I might give them blue armor.
Who knows?
Puffy up left.
I grab it behind you.
They're like over there, I think.
They're here right now.
I think more of them.
They're the same team.
One.
Cracked two.
Batting.
Reloading.
I'm coming in a second.
They're running through mine.
Okay.
I'm sipping here.
Oh, the sip is going to get...
Yup.
I'm...
I'm right behind.
Wait, they're under me or what?
Yeah.
Cracked half.
They ulted.
I met him quick.
That's fine.
I hope we don't get pushed from that.
Here.
Running away, running away.
Hard?
Is that nade from them or...
Yeah, I think so.
Right here.
Down.
I'm going to fall out here, okay?
Batting.
Sipping on me.
That new team behind us?
On me, on me, on me.
I'm stuck down here.
Let's run away.
I need to hold her.
She lived, but I need you to...
I'm batting, I'm batting.
Yeah, just play inside here.
Playing inside for now.
Yup.
Where are they?
Somewhere.
On the upper one.
Over there.
One guy here.
Someone here.
Oh, they bang ulted.
They're backing up over there.
Careful, that team behind us.
Calc.
Got smoked.
Being cracked.
I'm coming to you guys.
I don't see them right now.
They're zipping up, yeah.
Trying to come to you?
Yeah.
Slowly walking around like the big fat Newcastle ass here.
I can ball after them.
Yeah, I went in.
Someone here.
In the smoke, in the smoke.
I'm getting shot by the other team again.
I'm batting quick.
Alright, guys.
Oh, shit.
I'm batting.
Okay, I'm backing up.
Both teams are just running away, bro.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Yeah, they're scared.
They're so scared.
I have redeploy.
We need to use it.
They're ball calling.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, they're flashing.
One!
No!
I had to run.
He was so low.
I have redeploy.
Yeah, maybe.
I'm just gonna use it quick.
Are you smoking me?
Yeah, I was like, what do you mean?
Yeah, bro, let me smoke.
I'm smoking, I'm smoking.
Wait.
Alright, let's get lost, guys.
There's only two.
I'm bowling.
I'm heading over to you, guys.
There's only two.
For now.
Oh, my God.
Watch the ball!
No!
I got dodged in two!
That shit was scary.
Okay.
Um...
Let's just mirror them, I think.
They're close in front of me.
Let me know if you guys find energy ammo.
I just realized I barely have any.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm gonna craft energy ammo real fast.
Yep.
I can...
I'm slipping through the room.
Okay.
I set the balloon here.
Let's take the balloon.
I wish we had Valko right now.
I'm just gonna...
What?
Live?
Live, guys?
I'm not gonna live.
They've been on me.
Who's that duo?
I'm under.
I don't have med kit, so...
I only got one.
I can give you five.
Yeah, I'm syringing.
Another full team on the left side here, though.
Watch out, they don't slip on us.
I have one syringe left.
Yeah, I'll give you one.
Okay.
Is the safe coming here?
Yeah, I'm coming too.
They're chilling down there.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's go kill them, then.
I have a ball and...
10.
What about the other team?
It was the duo that I know.
Okay.
Blue armor.
Who are you shooting at?
Newcastle and Rampart.
I have both.
I'm syringing for myself on the left here.
What if I'm lucky?
Watch out, they're here though.
They're looking at me.
Blue.
I'm full healing.
I'm coming over now.
Fucking them up.
One more.
Rampart one.
Dead.
Nice.
I'm close.
Dropping down.
Both dropping down.
He's gonna curse him.
Rampart dead.
I'm dropping.
He's over there.
I see him.
He's grappling.
Where is he?
He grappled away.
Yeah, he grappled.
I'm going to zone.
I have no sip.
Okay, I need those.
Yeah.
I got it.
Let's go.
I'm heading over.
Every deploy we need it.
I don't think we're gonna kill him.
Wait, I'm... oh my god, how do I...
I have no sip, by the way, so hopefully we don't need it.
Rampart team in there.
There should be teams coming from right side.
We can gatekeep.
Shouldn't the Pathfinder solo be coming...
Okay, never mind.
I was gonna say.
Close, close, close.
And we're getting shot from left.
Save me, save me.
Okay.
Selling.
Watch out from here, maybe.
Yeah, I'm looking.
Can we take inside somehow?
Yeah.
They're inside, they're inside.
On me, on me.
Okay, I'm shot.
Where are they?
I don't understand.
Can you come up to me and ult?
Ulting?
What is this building?
Where are they?
Yeah, I don't know.
They're inside somewhere, bro.
They're like right below us.
No, no, no, they're right below us.
I mean, we're fine, though.
Yeah, we're fine here.
Uh-oh, I kicked you back.
I'm personal on below.
No, it worked.
What the fuck?
I'm batting.
Me too, I'm batting.
Pathfinder.
We should be fine, though, no?
We have zone as well.
Yeah, we have zone, we're chilling.
Smile, rotation, smile, rotation.
It was intentional, right?
Lucky it was so intentional.
Yeah, it was, it was, it was.
Encrypted him on those.
Yeah, I need to, I need to conserve my energy.
This one has to rotate.
This one has to rotate next to us, by the way.
I'mma ping.
When zone's closing, you just Q here, okay?
Okay, okay.
Like, you Q our back, and then we can peek.
Okay.
Yeah, Q this thing off.
Put a wall there.
Put a wall over there?
Okay.
Yeah, they put a wall.
Okay, I'm not really gonna shoot.
I can't shoot either.
I need to conserve my energy.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Oh, he's like, no, it's Newcastle below us.
Yeah, by the way, I don't know if this...
Yeah, yeah, here.
I don't know, you just can't get a box, you can see.
With the scraper in the game.
I have ult excel too, if I need to use it.
I know, it's gonna throw us one there, I think.
Can you, you're here in a second now?
Yeah, I can.
So it blocks our back?
Yeah.
I'll let you know when it's...
They're breaking our wall, by the way.
Yeah.
Okay, how long for next wall?
They're right below us, just using the horn.
How long do you need for next wall?
Um, 87%, 88%.
Okay, we'll be fine.
You can have some one-shots, by the way.
What do you want me to ult next, then?
Just the same, maybe again.
It depends on the zone, then.
Okay.
Just wait.
Okay, I'm not like...
Wait, I wanna...
I wanna figure out this building.
You can play low on me better as well.
Isn't there a person here, down here?
Okay, I think the entrance is other side here, by the way.
Okay.
I'm peeking the strats here a bit.
Wait, on me, on me, on me!
I got a shot, I got a shot.
I need a heal.
Nice.
Two guys there.
I'm batting.
I'm here, I put a wall behind us.
Over here, I don't peek.
Can you watch this?
Yeah, can you just make sure they're not pushing us?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm watching.
Can you kill the solo, maybe?
Oh, no, no, it just gets him up there.
Cracked one.
I don't have... I have ult now.
Okay.
It's fine.
I don't have Q, I don't have Q.
Are you burning him?
Yeah, it's fine.
He's resing.
Can't see him.
He's gonna pick him up if you see him.
Yeah.
Fuck me.
Just break this shit.
Oh, okay.
I don't have that much ammo, that's why.
Yeah, same.
Yeah, I don't think any of us have much ammo.
I have a shield.
I hear people below They're not looking, but...
They're...
They can only come from the other side.
You got zapped, bro.
We're still in, so we can just chill.
I know, I know.
Okay, okay.
Let's chill for a second.
I have two cells, by the way.
Okay.
Oh, I have a lot of bats, but two cells.
I have a lot of bats.
Someone's close now, by the way.
They might move.
Move.
Oh, no more Q.
They're under here now, by the way.
They're duo.
We're still in zone.
Let's see.
I have Phoenix, sorry.
That's fine, that's fine.
Zip on us.
They might be playing on top of us.
Yeah, we're shot.
Can you make a new wolf?
Is he energized?
Oh, shit!
He's coming!
Do you have Q?
Yeah, yeah.
Q-ing?
I got hit by the...
Batting?
I'm shielding, guys.
Okay, I'm med-kitting.
I'm just med-kitting, okay?
Yeah, you can rez after.
Let me rez after a second.
We'll play up here.
Yeah, rez now.
Oh!
That'll be good.
No, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, it's fine.
Just live.
Can you take this off from her box?
Yeah, just armor shop, yeah, yeah.
You good?
Ho, ho, unlucky.
Ho, ho.
Oh my god, I got pinned.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I don't know that I was smart.
Yeah, what were you cooking over there?
Fine, it's fine.
There's only six squads left.
Med-kitting.
Med-kitting, med-kitting, med-kitting.
I believe in you guys so much, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Alright.
Okay.
Here you come.
You have bats?
I'm 0-4.
Thank you.
Okay, I still have full team below us.
And I think, by the way, I think the duo is under us.
Like this little walkthrough, you know?
Yeah.
Can we just get some info?
Bow here.
Both bats on me too.
I'm gonna destroy this fucking gap here.
Oh, we gotta go.
I think.
I'm batting.
We have time a little bit.
Let's go after the thing.
Alright, bad, bad, bad.
In front of us.
One died.
I can't right now.
Yeah, I know, I know, I'm batting.
I'm batting.
Can we play somewhere?
You have zip?
No, yeah.
Can you zip inside here, bottom?
I'm zipping balloon, bro.
Bro, fucking deadslap.
I'm taking balloon second.
There's two teams up there, bro.
I'm so smart, bro.
Jump on the roof, jump on the roof!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
And come to me, we jump this side.
Yeah, yeah.
When you're with me, okay?
Yeah.
You're with me?
Let's go, I have to jump.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, go.
There's full team below us.
Puffy on me.
Yep, yeah.
Walk inside.
Kill him.
Walk, walk, walk.
Dead.
Swapping.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys coming.
Cracked them all.
Swing, swing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm making it inside, making it inside.
Save me.
You're coming, you're coming.
I'm holding.
There's team below us.
Yeah, yeah.
It's fine.
I'm holding.
I'm getting some loot for us.
Okay.
Can we break up?
I'm good, I'm good, actually.
I'm 1-5, I'm 1-5 only.
Top 4, by the way, top 4.
This team here, I'm gonna kill them, I'm gonna fuck them, okay?
Look, I'm not in here.
They're cooking, bro.
They're so cooked.
They're cooking!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Holy shit!
Left, left, left.
Look at Newcastle, yeah.
They're cooking!
Look at the zone, the way it comes on.
Look at the zone, look at the zone.
Come to the stairs, come to the stairs, come to the stairs, come to the stairs.
I know where everyone is.
There's someone in Newcastle.
Outside, outside, he's outside.
Outside?
Look in here.
Yeah, I'm looking.
I'm holding left, they're fighting.
What about left, though?
The one on the left, the one on the left.
He's dying, he's looking right, he's looking right.
Hold, hold, hold, hold, hold.
Dead?
Holy shit!
Holy fuck!
You guys are...
That was insane.
I was cooking.
You guys were cooking, that was fucking insane!
Bro, the oop play was insane.
Oh my god.
We fucked that team.
Holy fuck!
That shit was so crazy.
You're like, I'm cooking them, I'm cooking them!
You threw like six fucking nades at that poor guy.
Yeah.
Oh my god, bro.
Guys, that's the MVP, guys!
That's the...
Who did we kill?
SkinnySigma, who would've done that?
You guys did it.
Who the fuck is SkinnySigma?
I think it was them.
That oop play was golden, bro.
Holy shit.
Yeah, that shit was crazy.
That was crazy.
That was good, that was good.
That was good, that was a good game.
Yeah.
No, I didn't miss the balloon zip!
I saw it!
I came back just when they zipped up!
That's crazy.
That was such a gamble.
Like, I can't believe it worked.
Yeah.
I literally saw like six people looking at us and I was thinking that Z-Pro.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I can't believe you guys lived!
I don't know, it was just the oop play.
It was insane.
Like, I still came back and you guys were like 20% HP and I was like, what the fuck?
Yeah, I don't know.
Same.
We figured out our comp.
We figured out our game plan.
That was it.
The first game was worth it.
It was a warm up.
It was so planned.
Yeah, they were so planned.
It wasn't like, should we go here?
Oh hey, it's free!
Nobody's here, let's stay here!
Look at that.
This is it.
We figured it out.
I wonder which team was the one we killed.
Oh, team 11.
That poor team.
Oh, we killed Fulci's team.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
I like how he was so sad about it.
I could hear it in his voice.
This is it, guys.
We're locked in.
Now we have one more game and then a 30 minute intermission where we get unlocked.
Oh my god.
30 minute intermission to get unlocked.
That's actually insane.
This is it.
Team fucking cooked!
My death was their character arc.
They literally leveled up after I died.
They leveled up after I died.
It was worth dying.
They had to lock in after that.
They're like, oh shit, it's just the two of us.
She left and they were no longer sick.
My sick...
Yeah, yeah, the debuff was gone.
After that.
It's crazy.
Oh my god, alright.
I wonder what our seventh game is gonna be on.
Our seventh game is on...
Oh, it's on Storm Point.
So we have shitty loot for four games.
Oh no.
No, why did we vote for a seventh game?
Can we change the water thing?
Yeah, can we change back to no?
Yeah, I'm down, I'm down.
We voted no.
Why are we playing an extra game?
Alright, I voted no.
I took my vote away too.
I took my vote away and voted no.
It's okay.
If we win like four more games in a row, then the seventh game won't matter.
True.
Yeah.
Nobody can catch up after that.
I believe.
I can fly.
I believe I can touch the sky.
Look at that.
You're so locked in.
I wonder if they're going to do the same thing.
The other team.
Or are they going to run away now?
I don't think they will come again.
Oh, they got scared.
They're like...
I hope they do.
I hope they're like, we can win this.
We took down Effect that one time.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I was myself in that fight, can't lie.
Don't be like...
I was shooting the guy far right.
I shot the guy far right too.
I traded with him.
He gave me 100, I gave him 120.
Yeah.
I hope they come back so we can get free points.
We need those three kills.
Those extra three kills.
For real.
Oh my god.
Why are we...
Start game.
Ready.
Are.
Yeah, true.
Taking so long.
Yeah.
Where's the third game?
Are they doing promos right now?
They told me it was in the 30 minute intermission.
I can take a nap, dude.
In between that.
True.
Nap time.
Oh, they're doing replay.
Oh.
Oh, they're replaying us?
Why are they replaying us?
During like...
Because we won?
No, but this is like the fight, the first fight.
When we chased people.
And then they all ran away.
Bro, that game was weird as fuck though.
Yeah, they were all like...
We ran in circles and just trying to find one of the other teams.
Yeah, yeah.
They all like ran in circles around us because it felt like they were working together.
They'd be like, we can't give them kills.
Let's...
Yeah.
Oh, now our replay is gone.
Our replay.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay, now they're replaying how the final...
I like how you guys were just there.
The fact you guys just let them fight.
That's crazy.
They're really just chilling in the corner.
The Mad Maggie was such a good pick.
Yeah.
Is the queue getting a separate wall though, by the way?
If you shoot into it?
Yeah.
There's like a small timing before that.
When it's not as up...
Like when it's not activated yet, you know?
Okay.
Oh, that is interesting.
Third place is...
Dragon's team.
I'm not surprised.
Oh my god, let's go.
Let's go, finally.
This game, baby.
I believe.
We have a loot path for that shit POI too.
We could scroll up and loot paths and find it.
That would be true.
Oh, no we don't.
Because it was like for Launchpad 2.
Oh yeah, true.
I mean, it's fine.
We'll just figure out something.
We can figure it out, I believe.
We figure things out live.
Is it?
We don't need an actual IGL.
We all just flagged.
Our rotation was perfect.
We didn't even need to IGL.
Yeah, I know, right?
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Like everything just happened.
We don't need an IGL.
It just happened.
The zone came to us.
Yeah, the zone came to us.
Nobody was there in like the rotations we rotated in.
Wait, that's a bit of shit server me.
I got 10 packs.
I got 150 ping.
I'm lagging a bit.
Tell them to restart.
RESTART!
It would be good for sure.
I'm at 20 packs lost.
220 pings.
Woah.
Tell them to restart.
They will have worse.
Maybe try restarting the game.
Yeah.
I can message and be like restart request.
I'll do it.
Are you going to restart?
Or restart your own game?
It's fine.
I'll just see the zone first and then I'll do it.
I can't believe it.
They nerfed us.
We did too well in the first game so they were like...
Yeah.
I have gold energy marker for someone.
Oh.
Give it to them.
Lucky.
I got purple as well.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll have it then.
Oh.
I need a Mosem.
I still don't know how to loot this efficiently.
I'm so...
There's just so much loot.
Yeah.
Don't be greedy.
Oh.
Hey.
Nemesis.
Is it better now?
I have to restart now.
I'm not restarting yet.
Oh.
Shit.
You're not even back.
You're still...
I'm dropping the gold energy marker on the Nemesis.
Okay.
Oh no.
He's still...
He's still AFK.
Yeah.
It takes a while.
I don't know how to...
I have a new PC.
I don't know why people's games take so long.
I mean, I think it takes for me so long because of my...
My ping?
My tab alt just takes long in general.
I think if I would play native it would be fine.
Alright.
I'll just use it.
I think it went away a little bit.
Alright.
Maybe with more people dying.
Ah.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Usually that works.
Ah.
It's fine.
Whatever.
I'll just play it.
This is game.
I don't care.
I have second modem.
Woo.
Nice.
That's all I need.
Where do we go?
I will.
Oh yeah.
Scan.
Yeah.
I'm gonna hit the...
I'm gonna get the cash here.
Yay!
I'm gonna go...
Scan quick.
I'm 2-4 by the way.
I didn't do too much yet.
12.
I didn't even get that.
That backpack is so far.
Using grapple.
I'm scanning.
I spotted our enemy.
Yeah.
Our team is still there.
Wanna go kill?
Yeah.
We're going to Homburg Lops.
There's a balloon you can take.
Can I take the balloon?
Yep.
Wait for you first.
So I know how to...
How to do this fly.
Am I right in 2?
They're here.
They opened the bin.
Yay!
We're coming for you.
It'll be funny if we died.
No.
We tried so hard to come over.
And then...
That's a new view to watch out.
Can I see you?
He's scanning me.
I think he's here.
That's 1%.
It's ours.
I'm going left.
Go left.
There's a guy left.
On top.
I'm trying to get to...
I'm the slowest.
I can zip up.
He's looking.
I'm burning him.
Push shield.
Half me.
Half cracked.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm with Effect.
I'm healing.
I need heal too.
I'm dodging Bangles.
I can...
I'm going bottom here.
I'm with Effect.
Maybe come from here.
Heal and up.
He's above me.
Yeah, I hear them.
I'm leading.
Where is Zip?
I'm playing up.
I can't go up right now.
I fucked up.
I cracked him.
Okay.
I'm covering you.
I'm going to shield too.
It's hard.
Maybe...
I have bottle.
Okay, ready?
I'm with you.
I'm with you too.
I can grab him whenever.
Grabbing up here.
I'm holding.
I'm going to syringe him just in case.
I'm here behind you.
In front of me on the cannon.
They are zipping away.
They are here actually still.
I'm batting.
Cracked Pathfinder.
Cracked 100.
I'm batting.
I'm batting too.
Coming.
I'm heading over now.
She's low.
I'm going to rez.
One shot.
You can kill her.
One left.
Plus one here.
Oh no.
I can't see.
I couldn't see them.
I was just lagging so much.
I was grappling.
Yeah, I couldn't see them.
That's fine.
At least we don't lag here.
Or the next game, right?
No.
Not with the wave.
Yeah, for like an hour or something.
No!
Oh yeah, we have to wait an hour.
Bro, what the fuck?
I'm fucking going to play a pub.
Yeah, it's going to take so long.
Yeah, it's going to be an hour.
It's actually going to be 30 minutes.
Yeah, maybe we shouldn't have pushed this team.
We have to wait 30 matches after.
No!
Fine.
We could play a pub if you mean.
I'm going to play a pub.
I'm going to go nap for an hour, actually.
You're going to nap for an hour?
Wait, really?
Bro!
I'm going to play a pub.
I can't do this for an hour.
I have nothing.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe we shouldn't have pushed that when you were lagging.
It was fine.
It wasn't that bad.
I mean, we were shooting havoc and shit because it was delayed lagging.
Yeah.
It was terrible.
That sounds fucking damn bad.
Yeah.
Yeah, man.
I couldn't see the Pathfinder.
He blended in with the red zone.
I was so confused there.
It was also their Pred player too, so that fucked me up.
I was like, no!
It's fine.
Oh, man.
What do we play on their map?
Oh, yeah.
Is it the one I get?
Yeah, what do we play?
Oh, yeah.
Is it the one I get?
I don't think so.
I don't know yet.
Alright, we'll figure it out.
Depends how we want to play.
It's just edge though.
Yeah.
We have different teams around us this time.
Who's next to us?
I think they're like...
We have Dragon's team next to us to our right.
And then, I don't know who's left side is, but...
Dragon's next to us.
And then, Fun is next to Dragon.
So, most likely...
I mean, it'd be easier to push left team than right team.
Because they're there.
Yeah, we'll see.
I mean, definitely want to play Path.
But, I don't know what else.
What do you want to play?
Just play what you want to play.
Well, I say Newcastle.
Okay.
Alright, I'll say Newcastle.
Oh my god, my fucking duo is AFK.
Are you serious?
Bro, I wanted to fucking practice.
Oh my god.
I did a pub and he's AFK.
And I can't practice.
Shake your head.
Shake my head.
Alright, I'll die instantly, I guess.
I
guess I'll play Bang.
You'll play Bang?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's good.
Stormpoint.
Is this Stormpoint like a Bang map?
Yeah.
I don't know if it's shot.
We can play Newcastle.
Yes, we do.
You play Newcastle still?
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, I don't know what to play.
Other than...
Other than Newcastle.
What the fuck?
I also haven't been paying attention to competitive Apex in a long time.
So, I have no idea.
What is meta now.
Yeah, like Newcastle-ish.
Anyways, like Newcastle.
Yeah, I saw a lot.
Other than Newcastle, I don't know what else people play.
Crypto.
Crypto?
Do we play Crypto?
I mean, I can if you want me to.
You want me to play Crypto?
I think Newcastle is better.
Okay, I'll play Newcastle.
I'll play Newcastle.
Don't we play one mana?
We don't.
Play what?
We play four more Storm Point now, right?
Yeah, we play four Storm Point and then it's over.
If we get another first place, then we're in a safe area.
For that $100, guys!
Oh my god.
$100.
Yeah, because we have two zero-point games.
Why were you lagging?
I don't know.
Yeah, why were you lagging?
Why were you throwing, man?
I don't know, man.
If you weren't lagging, we could have won.
Yeah, I would have.
What do you mean we wouldn't have?
I mean, we would.
Oh, shit.
No!
My AFK guys left.
Holy shit, bro.
What just happened?
Yeah, I forgot, people.
I think that's better.
No, don't kill me.
That guy's one.
Oh, she's one.
Selling.
Oh, you guys are playing rank?
Yeah, yeah.
I thought I was going to take a fucking nap.
Coming?
Probably should have.
It's too late now.
Yeah, you guys are playing PredRank.
I don't want to do that.
They already crafted banners on me, I think.
That ain't for me right now.
Yeah, of course they're playing rank.
Effect is like rank 535 right now.
I got put down.
I just got too pumped.
By the golden Valk.
Why did you guys duck?
Damn.
That guy's probably down.
Guys, I'm a pumped player right now, guys.
I just know when I'm playing rank.
I'll get on the banner, by the way.
Good job.
He's still on you, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, I got it.
Thanks, man.
Nice.
Fucking massive, bro.
Shit.
Whoa.
Did you guys live?
Yeah.
I knew it.
I always believed in you guys.
I believe a lot in Effect, too.
Oh yeah, sorry.
I only believe in Effect, as well.
Hey, hey, hey.
Guys, let us know when the game is...
Let us know when the game is over.
So then we can time the 30 minutes.
So we can do the 30 minute timer.
It's so crazy that it's 30.
I feel like it should be less than 30 minutes.
It should be a lot.
It's actually a lot.
Yeah, it's a lot for shouting out sponsors.
I feel like...
I guess if it's like...
I feel like if...
I guess if they requested it to sponsor the tournament, I guess that makes sense.
But still...
Oh my god, it's...
Crazy, man.
And you get warmed down.
It's not even warm up anymore.
I think we have four games then.
The first one is going to be for the warm up, too.
We gotta like warm up again.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I trolled there.
Got bats from you?
Whoa.
I didn't want that.
No!
I don't think he had...
I thought this was...
That was his other...
That wasn't his teammate.
Fighting.
East.
Nice creation, XVI.
I'm so safe.
Graves, please.
Mm-hmm.
Please.
Planting above it.
Oh, thank god.
This won't hurt.
Hold on.
Bang one shot on you.
Mm-hmm.
Dead.
Whoa.
Hey.
I need shields.
I'll be close.
I hope we got an enemy.
Are you serious?
Okay.
I got fucked up.
In my little pub game.
I got double...
I got double headshot.
Okay, that makes more sense.
What the...
That guy.
Did you get fucked up?
Yeah, I did.
Bro.
What is going on?
Why is this random guy?
This is the most passive duo ever.
Oh, nice shots, though.
Need to recharge my shields.
Holy.
Where's the last one?
No idea, bro.
I mean...
These guys were more separated than anything else in my life.
Holy shit.
Oh, you're a third?
Fuck am I watching?
Last one.
Stay up.
I need to recharge my shields.
Yeah.
Nice.
Yay, my duo won his... Oh, he's controller.
Yay!
That's pretty much...
Defect and unlucky right now.
Scanning your V.
Nobody here.
What the fuck was that?
That's called...
This guy pushed up to him and died.
Because my duo was a controller player.
Bro, looking like a nap angle out here, bro.
I can't lie.
It's just...
Bro, I don't know.
I'm so low-key now.
Are you?
I feel amazing, I can't lie.
I don't at all.
I'm ready to win.
I'm so good, bro.
I can't lie.
The longer it gets, the more sick he's getting.
Yeah, I just...
He's feeling it.
His temperature is like, I don't know, like 500 degrees.
He's feeling it right now.
My eyes are like burning and like...
All the ambulance, that's all I'm saying.
I feel so confident right now.
With this team.
Don't worry, don't worry.
He can do it.
He just gotta lock in, you know?
He just gotta lock in.
I think behind us, too.
Guys, let us know when the game ends so we can time the 30 minutes, guys.
We're all in life support right now.
Effect is our life support.
As the only healthy person in this team, he's our health support.
He's our life support.
He's our health support.
Alright, 30 minutes starts now.
Let's go.
What the hell?
Revenant cracked.
Cracked to all this.
Save them.
Okay guys, I have a proposal.
If we win the next three games, we can leave early because nobody will be first place after that.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I'm just saying, if we win all three in a row, we could literally leave and don't have to play the seventh game and still be first.
I feel like that's the strat, guys.
I'm okay with that.
Oh, Lehman.
What the fuck?
Oh, of course there's a fucking second player!
Why am I always getting thirded?
I hope you die.
First place team in game three got 13... 18 kills?
Jeez, that's crazy.
It's always like, one team that... it's just one team that gets like all the kills.
Choked.
Wait, bring it on.
Wait, is second place getting kills or what?
Second place gets... there is prizes for second place too.
Wait, let me double check.
Wait, did I die?
Did my team die?
Okay, I can re-kill.
Let's see, where the fuck is the... second... okay, second place is a hundred dollars each player.
First place is a hundred and seventy-five dollars per player.
And then third place is fifty dollars per player.
Oh, W.
Yeah, so we could get W.
Yeah, I got shooting.
What the fuck, man?
Oh yeah, Dragon's team got first place, by the way.
Okay, not good.
Bro, Chiller's here.
Yeah, fuck me.
Wait, fourth round is starting soon?
There's no way, the lobby code isn't even out.
Don't lie to us.
Is it the same lobby code?
Help.
You literally told us there's gonna be an intermission.
So are we playing?
No intermission?
I don't know.
I feel like we'd get added if there was...
No, no, uh, people don't know yet.
Oh, they're doing team interviews, so yeah, it's gonna take like fucking forever.
Oh shit.
Do you really trust chat?
Of course not.
Only when they're backseating me.
Yeah, no, they're saying that there is a 30 minute intermission right now.
So we're back.
That's like two ranked games.
Yeah.
And like six pubs.
Six pubs is crazy.
Oh, I
got that.
We aren't gonna interview?
What the fuck would I say in the interview chat?
We're sick.
You're like, I don't know what.
We're sick and we don't know what we're doing.
I'm left.
I don't exist.
I'm not here.
All right, down we go.
I'm left.
I don't exist.
I'm not here.
How did you.
Oh yeah, I could chill in my fucking sponsor code.
Just give me a gun.
Kill.
I knocked the path.
There's no way which hate, bro.
Oh my god.
Can I step on here?
Yeah.
Wait.
They're below you, there's an enemy team.
Oh, it was them?
What the fuck?
It's you're.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
I got naded from this way.
No, no, no, I'm dead, bro.
Okay.
Why, man?
I'm getting naded.
No!
You sure you're dead?
Yeah, I believe in unlucky.
Bro's dead.
I'm dead.
Bro, what the... why did he just...
Oh, okay.
You wanna know what's our teammate's name is?
That he's shooting with the REA.
What?
No!
No, this guy...
What, Eager?
What the fuck are you doing?
There's no...
Oh, now you fucking play with me?
What the fuck is that guy?
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Oh, it's a shooter, by the way.
The lobby's shooting.
You got me?
Yeah.
Probably you.
Watch your back.
I won't always be around.
Upgraded.
Ah.
Alright, I'm gonna walk you down.
It's the plan of the sieg legging, bro.
What do you mean?
It's just so goofy.
Wait, one got knocked.
Yeah, the guy you knocked already knocked.
Bro, find a mob at res.
Come on.
There's no mob anywhere.
Yeah, it's a shooter.
Yes, full kill him.
He knocked one of the other team too.
Get the shooter on the right.
Fuck him up.
No, fuck him up.
Onefino.
And why this one got far right?
It's your word.
Alright, I muted... I muted my old Discord.
We'll hear them, but I wanna talk to you guys.
Dad is at babysat... Dad is getting babysat right now.
Because I can't take care of a dog at the moment.
So...
I can't take care of dogs at the moment.
So he's getting babysat.
The worst part was that when I gave him to the...
I found a babysitter at the very last minute.
It was very expensive.
But I literally could not take care of a dog in my condition.
And I gave the leash to the babysitter and he didn't look back.
I was so...
He just left.
He just kept walking.
I was so fucking sad.
I was like, alright, here you go.
Here's the leash.
And he was so happy because it was a lady.
I made sure it was a lady.
I made sure it was a woman that's babysitting him.
And then I gave... like, you know...
He saw... he saw the lady and he was so happy.
He was like, Yippee!
Woman!
And like jumped on her.
He was like, I love woman!
And then...
And then he fucking...
He like...
I gave the leash to her and then he didn't look back.
He didn't even look at me.
He didn't...
He just walked away.
He literally...
He literally just walked away.
I'm just like...
Oh my god.
I was like, I guess...
She is a lady, that's for sure.
What the fuck is this guy doing?
That is such a womanizer.
I didn't think the shield came back that fast.
So yeah, that's the life update.
So far.
He is now at the babysitter.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh fuck, okay.
Oh god, my fucking sick...
Oh my sick aim!
Where is my octane?
Please, I got him so low.
Oh no!
Anyway, so that's the update.
That's the...
That's the update for my life at the moment.
The...
And then I got sent updates and then the owner...
Sorry, I'm the owner.
The babysitter texted me an update today.
She's been giving me updates the last three days.
And then today I got an update from the babysitter.
And then he was like...
She was like...
Oh my god.
He was...
He was such a...
Say Stariboh.
Stariboh.
What the fuck does that mean?
Nothing.
Can you say it again?
What?
How do you say it?
Stariboh.
What?
What does it mean?
It's just like a streamer.
He says it all the time.
He says...
Don't say that.
It's like a big meme in Dota.
Stariboh.
Don't say that, you're gonna get banned.
Jocked.
Yeah, am I gonna get banned?
Am I gonna get banned?
Guys, anyone that knows...
Is that Russian?
Yeah, it is.
Any Russians in my chat, what the fuck does it mean?
We just insulted everyone.
I'm sorry.
This is a fix fall.
If it's an insult.
If it's not, then like...
Yay.
Stariboh.
Wave that.
One guy bomb left and that guy's like...
I got put down.
Okay, so like, basically, anyway, it's a game, there's no way, there's no way it's a game.
Anyway, anyway, so...
Yeah, the gold of playing out of a list, oh my god.
Anyway, what was I gonna say?
Okay, so, she gave me an update and was like, hey, so...
So he was a really, okay, I'm gonna be frozen for a bit, guys.
I need to reread the text.
I was so, like, I was like, are you serious?
He was an angel overnight.
Very quiet.
And I was like, is this the same fucking dog?
He's such a cutie and very playful.
I am loving having him here.
It's okay.
Fucking women.
That's the opposite.
This Brad talk.
Betrayed.
I can't believe it.
Bro, what am I doing?
I just, I'm just thinking, are we clearly talking about the same fucking dog?
You have some strangers for me?
No, he's not gonna like the male babysitters.
He fucking hates men.
He only, he only likes women to take care of him.
Fucking, God, fucking, I can't believe it.
When I got that text, I was like, are you, what?
Is this the same fucking dog?
Like, did they, did they swap dogs?
Like, what do you mean?
He wasn't, he was very quiet.
That part fucking confused the shit out of me.
Because if anything, that is not quiet.
He is not fucking quiet at all.
My controls, do you see it?
So I was like, he was quiet.
And I was like, excuse me?
Like...
I'm gonna push your castle.
Excuse me?
Okay, I'm choosing the Angela.
Is someone else on you, by the way?
Yep.
Alright.
I love my dog.
But just sometimes.
Ooh, sometimes.
Oh no, mental pookie.
Sometimes.
Ooh.
Yeah.
He's just, he's just shy.
No, he was so happy.
He was so fucking happy.
I literally was like...
I literally like gave the babysitter a leash.
And then he like never looked back at me.
He just left.
Literally just kept going forward.
I was like...
I looked at him to see if he'll walk...
Like, you know, I want to see if he'll at least look at me.
But he didn't.
He didn't even look at me.
That was the worst part.
Like...
I would have accepted him looking at me at least once.
But he didn't.
That was...
That hurt, guys.
That actually hurt.
Yes, sir.
He just whipped it out.
Huh?
You want to punch him?
Come here.
He was so scared.
One, two, three.
He was wagging his tail.
Anyway.
That's my life update.
I can't take care of any...
I can barely take care of myself at the moment.
I'm so fucked up.
I literally...
For the Pico Park 2 collab, I was playing with a headache.
But I was trying...
But I didn't want to reschedule it.
Because it was with a lot of people.
You know?
So I felt really bad rescheduling it.
Because a lot of people gave up their time to play today.
But like...
Oh, my God.
I was so...
I was not okay.
Like...
I know it didn't seem like it.
It might not have seemed like it.
But I had a headache by the end.
Yeah.
I went outside too much.
You know?
During my going outside character arc.
I went outside a little bit too much.
Oh, that guy's a bot.
I'm just going to kill this guy.
He's AFK.
That poor guy.
I'm just going to kill this guy.
I don't think he's even going to try and res him.
Is he actually going to even try to res this guy?
Hello.
Why?
Okay.
That's free loot at least.
Has he even looted?
Oh, he has.
He just was AFK for that one moment.
That was so sad.
He was just...
He just had to be AFK today.
I am so bad.
Poor guy.
Am I pushing you?
How does he see me in smoke?
I'm on your right.
Poor guy.
No, I just, I just, I have to go.
I think, I don't know what got me sick.
It could be anything, honestly.
It could be anything that got me sick because like I was doing so much stuff in general.
I had to do a lot of things today.
Not today.
I mean like over the weeks that got me sick.
Oh, he died to another team.
Yeah.
So like, uh, so that, I don't know.
I don't know.
It could be in anything.
I went outside a lot.
I had to go to the vet.
I had to do banking stuff.
Um, I had to go outside for, uh, for a meeting.
I could, I'm also like incredibly stressed too.
So like, and really overworked in general.
So it could be that as well.
So like that like kills your immune system when you're, when you're like...
Uh, when you're like stressed and overworked, cause I'm like always working.
I'm always working.
Tell your boss I am my own boss and I'm not in my, and as a boss, we're not taking a break.
We're just gaming.
No breaks, no breaks for me.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
I'll just throw this nade in.
Yup.
That's fucking right.
Oh my.
That's a Loba.
She might be sus.
No damage.
I'm fine.
I think too.
It's fucking right.
My house now.
Wait, what?
This was supposed to be my house.
What the fuck is going on?
My, my reaction is not good right now.
It's like super noticeable.
My reaction is so slow.
So much better, bro.
Rabbit, bro.
The fuck is rabbit?
Rabbit.
Rabbit, bro.
I have such a slow reaction.
Oh, man.
Fucking rabbit.
You are not good in Apex.
Hey.
Oh.
Wait a second.
Chad, you're not good in Apex.
To your ass.
Bro, why is my chat is in German now?
Wait, what?
What?
Why is it in German?
Oh, fuck.
I canceled my heal because you said that.
I was so surprised.
Okay.
How long do you have still?
I have no idea.
Chad, how long do we have till we get to play the game?
Time for an app.
Wait.
Apparently, you said something in German.
That's why.
What the fuck did you say?
You're so multilingual.
What?
Multilingual?
Apparently, Apex said something in German.
Oh, shit.
No, I got fucking destroyed.
Chad, cancel.
Wait,
in fact, how many languages do you know?
Only two.
All of them.
Nah, only two and a bit from different languages.
Wait, what do you know from different languages?
Apparently, there's two mids left.
Random wars.
Like what?
Say one.
No.
Why not?
What the fuck does that mean?
I don't know.
It's in German.
Things that love you.
I don't think that's what it means, though.
He said it.
It does.
Okay.
Wait.
How would you know?
You're not German.
He's German.
I am.
Wait.
You are?
You're German?
Wait.
Let me.
Clearly, I didn't read the right Wikipedia.
Okay.
What the hell?
They speak German in Austria.
Oh yeah, dude.
Oh, you're Austrian.
I was like you're not German.
They speak German there.
Yeah, yeah.
I forgot.
They speak German in Austria.
You're not German.
You're not from Germany.
Okay.
Love it.
Sorry.
I just knew you weren't from Germany, so that was like you're not German, but I forgot you're Austrian.
That's okay.
I'm a parent.
The very word in German is Gnsehalsen.
What does that mean?
It means goosebumps from balls, bro.
Goosebumps from balls?
Yeah, goosebumps on your balls.
Oh my god.
How did you learn that word?
I don't know.
No, you know.
You know how.
Did you teach him these words?
No.
No, I taught him these words.
That's the thing.
I taught him.
Yeah.
Oh man.
Maybe Effect is a bad influence.
Maybe.
That's crazy.
Who the fuck is Rario in the chat, bro?
Rario?
I don't know.
Goat.
Yeah.
Oh, somebody wrote it for me.
Gnsehalsen?
How do you pronounce it?
Gnsehalsen.
That's good.
How do you pronounce that?
Gnsehalsen.
Is that goosebumps on your balls?
Yeah.
Damn.
So what is the context?
What context?
Just say it randomly.
There's no meaning.
Yup.
That's context.
Yeah.
You guys don't have Gnsehalsen?
It's not a common thing.
Sometimes you just get goosebumps.
Yeah.
On your balls.
You're so scared, you just get it on the balls.
Yeah.
Experienced that already.
Just got so much use.
Exactly.
You can use it every day.
Damn.
How many languages do you know?
How many languages do I know?
Well, okay, I know English, Chinese, French, and then I used to know a little bit of Korean, but I don't anymore because I don't, like, practice it.
A lot.
Yeah, but I...
I've learned Japanese and Chinese, too.
Oh, Chinese is really hard to learn.
Yeah.
How's your Japanese?
Oh, he says YouTube into Japan!
How is it?
Well, I'll learn it one day.
It was good.
Yeah, what do you guys do in Japan other than the Tokyo Game Show?
Intercourse.
Oh, shit!
With each other?
No, uh, yeah.
I'm not letting it anymore, it's crazy.
Oh my god.
I am hiding it.
I'll join the team later.
That's why he joined Alliance, right?
So you guys can get closer.
Yeah, it was dark.
It was dark.
Hard to tell who was who.
Oh, shit.
I don't know, maybe it was Pontus, maybe it was Effect.
I don't know.
Wow!
That's why you guys work so well together, you know?
In bed and out of bed.
Yeah.
That's where the dick in the ass comes from.
Wait, who's the...
Who's the top?
Huh.
Who's the more dominant one?
It's getting kind of freaky out here, alright?
It's getting kind of freaky.
I got Gensokun.
Gensokun's the same, bro.
That wasn't the one that started this conversation.
I literally asked him about Japan.
Somebody else.
Somebody else decided to bring in your relationship with each other.
I think it should be starting soon, by the way.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should pay attention to that, right?
Yeah.
Not the other stuff that was just leaked out.
But, like, he's your bro, you know?
You gotta do what bros gotta do.
Yeah.
Just bro things, no homo.
Yeah, it's just bro things.
People with no bros don't understand, right?
Oh, shit.
Only bros understand.
Huh?
Are you serious?
Wait.
Okay, so, like, my chat wants to ask you guys.
If one of you guys got bit by a snake...
Yeah.
Would the other suck the...
I already knew the question, dude.
Okay, so, in fact, we'll do it.
But would you do it, unlucky?
Oh, you have to think about it.
That's crazy.
I had to swallow my water.
You hesitated.
You had to hesitate.
Dude, that's crazy.
No, I was swallowing.
Oh, you swallow?
Yeah, I was swallowing.
What the fuck?
That's getting freaking freaker.
Oh, my God.
What do you mean?
You started it.
You literally started it.
I did not start it at all.
I only said I had intercourse.
I said the most family-friendly sentence ever.
That's not family-friendly.
What do you mean?
It is.
Intercourse.
I literally was asking how was Japan and then you started it off the best.
I always add intercourse.
That's all I add.
Damn, that's freaky.
Damn, I can't believe unlucky is so freaky, guys.
He's so freaky.
Freaky hunter.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, bro.
Oh, God.
I can't hate, man.
Damn.
The freakiest, bro.
Am I getting dragged or what?
Bro, it's just your style of game.
Oh, I don't wanna...
What the fuck?
Whoa!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait, is the lobby out?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, cool.
Fuck it.
Okay, it's just me.
Okay, I'll...
Where's my teammate?
Please!
Oh, he was one HP.
That's why.
That's why he's unlucky.
Damn.
Unlucky is the freakiest person I know.
And I just met him today.
Wait, am I the only one missing?
Oh, shit.
Goodbye, Pathfinder.
No.
Oh, wait, I'm not?
Okay, I'll keep playing.
Why can't I just be dragged?
Like, why is there just no one dragging me?
Bro!
You gotta drag yourself!
Damn.
Don't be lazy.
What about me?
No, no.
Unlucky is so freaky, you guys.
Effect can vouch.
Is Unlucky the most freakiest pro you've ever known?
He is freaky, bro.
Oh, shit.
Like, how freaky?
Well, they're like...
The freakiest person I know.
Oh, like, give me an example.
You have to say, yeah, and then not give receipts, you know?
Hell not.
There's too many things I don't know.
Bro, he literally got banned on Twitch for moaning.
What?
Did you actually?
That's not how it went.
For my defense, no.
I was 17 when that happened.
I was 17.
That's why I got banned.
That doesn't make it better.
Because you have mine.
Nah, I'm going toilet.
I'm disconnecting myself from this conversation.
Bye-bye, I'm going toilet.
It makes it worse, it makes it better.
It doesn't make it better if you're under 8.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
You're the only one missing, Ducky.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm the only one missing?
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright, I leave.
I'm so sorry.
Don't worry, Roman Lettuce.
I'll give you this shield, and then I'm gonna die here in this corner.
I'm sorry, I have to go.
Alright.
Where's the code?
Where is it?
Lobby?
Oh, is it the same code?
Oh, it is.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, I can just do that.
There you go.
Oh, I was the last one.
It's Teddy Reckless.
Teddy Reckless.
I wasn't the last one.
Teddy Reckless just got in.
Okay, after that conversation, we should be so locked in after that.
Yup.
He should be, like, ready to ready to frag.
With his freaky with his freakiness.
I wonder what he's doing in the bathroom right now.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, he leaves all of a sudden.
Gotta relieve some stress, right?
Yeah.
Gotta pee the stress out, right?
You're just saying that.
That's what you mean, right?
Yup.
Hope he come back by the time.
Yeah, I hope so.
Hope he pees fast.
Okay, we're playing...
Okay, I'm still on...
He's getting freaky.
He's getting...
Having...
I'm back from my toilet adventure.
I'm ready to poop on other people now, not only my toilet.
Why did it take you so long in the bathroom?
Cause I had to take a shit.
Yeah, that's what you call it now?
Yeah, that's what you call it?
Alright.
That was that fast?
I'mma keep it real?
That was...
That was pretty good.
Alright.
Let's go.
I don't even know where we're landing.
How we're landing, actually.
We're doing... We're devastated, Coast.
Oh, yeah.
Right side is Dragon's team.
Left side is I don't know who, but Dragon's team is currently first place.
Calm.
Freaky bird.
Freak fat and unfreaky.
No, he's the most...
What do you mean?
Oh, man.
Okay, I'm looting.
I'm looting top.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm looting south-east, I guess.
Waiting the UV or what?
Oh, I loot.
I loot here?
Question mark?
Yeah.
You should get nothing.
And freaky is for the irony.
Oh, man.
That's gonna be what you're known for.
For the rest of your life.
Oh, wow.
That's something I came proud of.
Yeah.
Yeah, man.
Be up.
Okay.
Alright, I'm running Carbine.
Carbine, Mozambique.
Yippee.
Very good.
I have double Mozambique, but I can't...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I should change my team name to Freaky at LAN.
Can we request a name change?
A team name change.
Real quick.
We got no cash.
Let's go, baby.
We have nothing.
Let's go.
I have nothing.
It's okay.
We can get...
We can win something.
We can get first place here in this map with this drop spot.
Yeah.
Have shit.
First launch by that.
There's an evac here if anyone wants it.
I have...
Cracked an enemy shield.
Back one.
Reloading.
They're gonna come now because I was beefing with them.
Oh, shit.
They're gonna come in the course of us.
I'm gonna loot this bin and we'll get plus 50.
Resm's finger.
There's a lot of bats here.
I'll take these.
Try to get one tapped.
You wanna go around right side or...
Sure.
There's a bat here.
And more shield cells.
They maybe wanna fight.
I think they want to because if they win the 50-50, they're gonna be our last threat.
Yeah, down here.
We need to get blue because he has sentinel.
Yeah.
He's running up here.
I feel like they're gonna play zone.
Yeah, they might.
He's just running up here.
I don't know where his teammates are though.
Where do we go?
We go left or...
Yeah.
I'll go grab the right one.
You can go for the left one.
You can just go up here.
Yeah.
I'm freaky.
I'll follow Mr. Freaky right now.
I'm gonna hit the UV here.
I wanna have sex with us.
Damn, he's already getting his freak on now.
He's getting his freak on.
It's late night.
It's freaky hours now.
He's locked in but like a different type of locked.
Oh my god.
Alright.
It's demon hours.
It's gooning hours.
Oh my god.
Bro.
You're just like no.
I can't focus.
Okay, we're locked in.
We're locked in.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
We're locked in now, right?
Oh my fucking god.
He's not locked.
He's not locked, guys.
What happened unlucky?
Leave me alone.
I'm not a pathfinder man, okay?
I only play character for fun.
Then why did you pick pathfinder?
I have to.
I'm forced out here.
If not me, who is going to...
What do you mean?
What do you mean forced?
You can pick whatever you fucking want.
I can play back if you want to.
Where was it?
Why did you put another one?
Why are you crushing my pathfinder gameplay?
Maybe if we swap pathfinder, maybe we'll win.
They hit you and me.
Why the fuck are these guys so late?
Yeah, what the fuck?
They're chasing a solo there.
Yeah, but what if this team is coming with me?
Yeah, there's a team coming in our back, so we might as well.
Is it a right angle?
I feel like it's a right angle.
I'll stay here.
I'll come up too.
Yeah.
I'm running with her.
Alright.
Are they coming?
They're ballooning.
The wall called it, bro.
Are they going to be here?
Are they going barometer?
Yeah.
Goddamn.
Alright.
Locked in for real.
Am I hitting the cannon or what?
No.
No?
Yeah, he's definitely not locked in.
I am, I am, I am.
Bro, you wanted to take the fucking cannon.
There's like two teams over there.
There's no one.
Alright, I swear I saw a gunshot.
Stars.
Where's the stars?
I'm hitting the beacon.
Shooting stars.
Can you smoke me?
Thank you, man.
Nice.
You're welcome.
It's okay, he's not...
Oh, fuck!
Oh shit, okay.
I was scared.
Blue armor.
That bang is healing.
Rampart.
Why am I playing Rampart?
It's a Newcastle Rampart team.
Should I go up to you guys?
Maybe.
Okay, I head over.
I'm looking right now, where are they?
Are they?
Do you see them?
Oh, they're here.
Yeah, there they are.
We can't pinch them, there's a team behind them.
Yeah, don't go right now.
Alright, I'm pushing up.
I'm gonna scrap the...
Ugh.
They're getting shot from a team to my left.
Yeah, they are.
They got down, they dropped off the high ground.
There's one inside.
Yeah, there's one.
Oh, we're kind of zoned.
Oh, nice.
I'm heading over.
We should need one more evil cash for purple.
Yes, sir.
We can scan that one.
Alright.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Alright, let's get that.
I'm zipped.
I'm gonna grab that purple.
And then I'll zip up.
Is there somebody here?
Is there anybody there?
Yeah, just kill him.
You're the unlucky.
Alright.
Alright, I'm here.
You're so safe.
Alright, I'm hitting either one.
Nobody loses, so that means there's nothing here.
Be calm.
There's a team here.
Yeah, let's go kill that team.
Let's go there?
Yeah, they're gonna go for the guys probably.
Alright.
One of them is so far.
I'm ballooning for myself.
I'm with Effect.
Whoa.
Not 10 seconds.
Looking to my left just in case.
I don't see anybody yet.
I'm still in building.
On the roof.
Yeah, purple armor.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
I'm ballooning.
Yeah, he's still there on that building.
Literally looked for one second.
There's a guy in the window too.
Yeah, I smoked him.
Is this a teammate?
No way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm wave.
Unlucky.
Okay, I'm playing him.
Oh, I'm with...
I'm batting.
He can maybe ult to Effect if he's fighting there.
I'm pushing up with you guys.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're back top.
Yeah, fucking nerds.
We can try to follow from tunnel.
We can walk up right side maybe.
Mm-hmm.
All the way right, you mean?
Yeah, you can scan him in.
Let's see if we can get further.
Let's hit the smoke me.
Yeah, shots up there.
They're bangling up there.
Should we just go up now?
Yeah, we'll fight them.
Low, below.
Should I hit the UV if I can though?
Yeah, do it.
I can shot.
It's fine.
Yeah, let's go up.
Yeah, yeah.
Go up?
Okay.
Don't let this team below you to see it though.
Oh, yeah.
It's a solo and a full team.
I got shot too.
Maybe.
I need a shield cell, full heal.
Hit this guy here.
Three, two, one.
It's all you.
I got one.
Nice.
Hang up still a bit.
Rampart.
Rampart cracked.
Rampart one.
Chop them.
Are we starting?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm burning one.
I can grapple in.
I'm pushing.
No, no, no.
No!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I got like 20...
I took every shot there.
They did everything.
It was all in my face.
Watch behind us, okay?
He is resing.
I'm going down.
I'm kidding.
I literally took every fucking gunshot possible in there.
Dead?
Nice.
I'm gonna get that 3x.
I'm coming over you guys.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
You can hold there.
Oh, hold up.
High ground?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
50 of them?
I don't have an angle.
Look at that.
Just hold tight.
We're fucking chilling.
Okay.
Just watch here, okay?
Watch this direction, okay?
Yeah, I'm watching.
I'm just gonna loot here.
Yeah, I'm coming in a second.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Okay, I'm good.
Meow, meow.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab...
Do you want the... I have a gold...
I have a gold ball.
Do you want that?
I'm good.
Actually, I can take it.
Yeah, here.
I dropped a purple too, so...
Or blue.
Alright.
Now you're freaky with the shotgun.
I'm watching right.
I don't see anybody on this side.
I'll drop down slowly.
Let me see some light ammo.
Some action.
Care package over there.
Here, by the way.
Shots maybe?
Wait, did I move bins here?
There's no more bins here.
Saw a Valka, by the way.
Our back's cleared, by the way.
True.
What the fuck is this?
Yeah, no bins.
What the hell?
Yeah, nobody's in the back.
I don't know if you got me with that one.
Alright, nice.
Good.
I'm gonna look at the magi quick a little bit.
Yeah.
I'm gonna conserve some ammo here.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here shooting me from that far?
Saw a Valks on this building, by the way.
I have stone pulse kind of dish.
I have real ploy.
Can we just sit blade, hide?
Yeah, we can.
We can even below, maybe.
Oh, even now?
I think there's someone.
We can oop them, maybe.
From here.
Yeah, but...
Can't you give me a balloon?
You're gonna get shot hard, though, from balloon.
No, we can... it's just balloon to bait, you know?
Oh.
We can drop left side, and then zip.
You know?
To the left.
You do have real ploy, too.
Yeah, you're gonna get shot in the ass.
That's so hard, though.
You wanna do it late, though?
I think you're doing it late, no?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just letting...
This team's gonna fuck us.
You have to smoke them, by the way.
Okay?
This team here.
This side.
Like, these windows?
I think it's most...
I mean, we can just hug and walk out, bro.
We don't even have to go for the roof.
We can blend below, like, on the building, no?
Can we?
We should make sure we don't get mirrored by this team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I'm watching right.
Yeah, so we're just gonna cross.
I'm gonna smoke the cross, yeah?
Yeah, it's a solo, it's a solo vehicle, I think.
No, it's full team, full team.
Full team vehicle, dude.
There should be a solo somewhere on the right side, if she didn't die.
If she didn't get killed.
Oh my god.
There's, like, light ammo here.
There's light ammo here.
Yeah, it's fine.
I dropped it.
I don't need it anymore.
I'm double... I'm fucking quadruple moza.
Oh, shit!
Quadruple moza!
Okay.
That's just crazy.
Yeah, that's crazy.
Wait, where do we go in Lucky?
Like, the two of us?
I'm just holding.
We're gonna go to Effect soon.
Okay.
Should I ulti you?
Yeah, I feel like you're gonna fucking say that.
Yeah, they're looking at me, so I can't walk safely.
Just walk down, Tim.
Should I go now?
Yeah, just come, come, come.
This is welcome.
I'm walking, I'm walking.
There's a team next to us playing Q somewhere.
The whole market's not in, though, by the way.
Just come to me, come to me.
Yeah, I just want them to not sip us here.
They can still sip us back.
I'll come later.
I'm here.
There's a team on the roof, Tim, inside.
Oh, where do we...
Wait, wait.
Both on the roof, careful.
Okay.
We're, like, safe here.
Oh, it's not really safe.
Can she wall somewhere?
Can you wall here?
Yeah, put a wall here.
I have the shield.
We can go bottom, we can go bottom.
Let's go bottom, let's go bottom.
I'm killing it.
Okay, okay.
Come below, come below.
Watch the stairs, though.
I killed one guy here, by the way.
Yeah, I killed him, too.
I need a full heal, I need a full heal.
Alright, alright, alright.
I got hit by a zone.
There's a full team in here.
I'm swinging.
That's you, that's you.
We have to watch the other team that's swinging us, that's why.
Okay, okay.
I'm coming.
There's a team that's swinging.
I'm shielding this.
Yeah, I'm coming.
Last one.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
They're pushing, they're pushing.
New team pushing, new team pushing.
I think if I just play for your life.
It's third party, third party.
Come inside, come inside.
She's gonna block it.
Okay, I'm out, I'm out.
I'll see if they're pushing stairs.
Crypto's pushing up.
Full team pushing up, pushing up, pushing up now.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to...
Why are they swinging, bro?
Are they stupid?
Yes.
They are.
They're swung in the same moment I said they're gonna do it, probably.
Yup.
Did we get kills for them at least?
Yeah, we got a couple kills for it.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Oh my god.
I didn't know how many...
Like after you said there was a full team inside of one building, I didn't know if you want to fight or not.
Because then I had to bat when you said you were swinging.
The small building.
Yeah, probably should have went back.
I mean, there's still five squads left, so...
Yeah.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
I can't believe they pushed that.
That's crazy.
They pushed that to lose.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
They couldn't handle it.
Yeah, that shit was insane.
We fucking killed so many people.
They didn't like our freak off.
They got jealous.
We're too freaky.
This team is just too freaky.
Yeah, didn't match our freak.
Even if we don't win, we're the content here.
For real.
I mean, we had a good game.
Yeah, that was a good game.
We got lots of kills too for it.
We just got fucking grief there.
I got shot in my back.
I went very back.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
Back shots.
Back shots are real, bruh.
Yeah, damn.
Yeah, if you had like Kalos or something to get their doors away, then we could have done like play outside.
Yeah, if only I shot my gun instead of throwing a nade, bruh.
The timing was crazy.
Kalos grappling as well.
I would have not gone for sure.
When I was walking up the stairs, I was so slow because I didn't realize I got back shots from the guy behind us.
Yeah, he was sitting on top of the thing.
I was so confused too.
I was so slow.
I was like, why am I going so slow?
I was so slow up the stairs.
I was like, commit, commit.
And I was like, I'm a bag of shit.
SkibitySigmas1!
Oh!
Oh no.
SkibitySigmas.
BussyBussies.
What did MonsunSigmas get?
I did?
Yeah, pretty much even with them.
Yeah.
They're back.
They're fucking back.
Why is my chat talking about back shots?
Nothing.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, did we die to the back shot team?
No, no, no.
Did we die?
Oh no, oh no, no, no.
Don't worry, we didn't get back shot by them.
Oh yeah, 8 kills.
Oh god, the SkibitySigmas with the fifth...
I swear, all the first place team has like insane amount of kills too.
SkibitySigmas.
Three more games.
See, he locked back in.
Unlucky locked in.
Huh?
I'm so, I'm so fucked.
What do you mean?
You locked in.
Struggles, struggles.
How are you struggling?
To be fair, you're sick too, so it makes sense.
Yeah.
You're so sleepy.
So sleepy.
You're so sleepy?
Oh, I was gonna say drink coffee, but you're like literally sick.
So, you can't drink coffee.
You drink tea.
Uh, yeah, I know.
I was so tired, I was drinking Red Bull.
Holy shit, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
You would drink Red Bull when you're...
when you're sick.
Yeah.
I had to, otherwise it's chalked.
Like, I was so tired.
Yeah.
Wait, did you not sleep?
Mmm...
No, I did a little bit, but when I woke up, like, 15 minutes before a tournament, I was like, just still tired.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, cause you just woke up type deal.
Yeah.
You're slowly waking up, right?
The longer we play, right?
Is that it?
Uh-huh.
I don't think that's it.
I don't think so.
Are you kidding me?
I'll fall to bad as soon as the tournament is over.
Okay, next game.
I'm not surprised that Dragon's team is winning.
They're like 20 points ahead of us.
It's fine.
Everyone's nothing.
We can still achieve that.
Yeah, yeah, it's okay.
We still have three more games.
We have three more games.
We'll just kill...
They're like, they're like literally behind, like right next...
They're like, they got, they're right next to us twice.
Yeah.
Yo, how's Lillibar looking?
Are we close to number one?
We are fourth place.
We're on...
We're fourth place.
Third place is two points ahead of us.
Or three.
Sorry, I can't do math.
Uh, it's three points ahead of us.
Three points ahead of us.
SkippitySigma is like second place.
That's crazy.
SkippitySigma is second place.
They've only got one first place.
I mean, how... I mean, we have fourth.
It's crazy.
To be fair, to be fair.
Yeah, we have two games.
Yeah, we won.
We have two games.
We have two games where we didn't even do anything.
So, like, I feel like us being... We were experimenting, okay, guys?
We were...
We were theorycrafting in two games.
But now we know our limits.
So we won't do that again, right guys?
We won't make mistakes now.
Um...
Guys, we haven't played together before.
Guys, as a team.
So we were... Yeah, it's the first time.
And we're literally nerfed so hard.
I mean, if you didn't have this one game, I was lagging, you know?
That's true!
If he wasn't lagging...
Like, if he fixes his internet, things would have been fine.
True, bro.
Move out of Australia.
Yo, my bad.
I'm moving to Tokyo, bro.
You got me.
Yeah, yeah, you should move to Tokyo.
I think there's someone else who got you.
Huh?
Excuse me?
What?
Us?
Shit, you're moving in with Effect?
Oh my god!
One bedroom?
That's my dream, bro.
You really...
We learn how to cook together.
Oh!
We all just go to town alone by those fucking sandwiches all the time.
Oh yeah, the convenies?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We need to cook.
That's true.
That blood cook.
Oh my god.
Never have to cook again.
I mean, the reason why they're getting one bedroom is to save rent, guys.
It's expensive for them.
Yeah, man.
Yeah, they gotta save rent.
The bed is probably like half of what one was probably.
How are we gonna fit on it?
It's gotta be extra close.
Restarting game crash and blur.
Squeezed up.
What the hell?
Yeah, my controller's having a seizure right now.
Oh shit.
My controller just DC'd 15 times.
Match ended.
Nice.
Scrims.
And they were just roommates.
Exactly.
They're just roommates, guys.
Yeah.
They're just roommates.
How do you play?
What the fuck?
Nah, bro.
That's so rude.
What does that mean?
I'm playing like a cancer.
What?
Clippy, for damn timing you out, man.
Damn.
Look at that.
Bro's...
Yeah, how could you say that to his bro like that?
Man, I thought you were gonna say nice words like you're so beautiful or some shit.
Yeah, you gotta teach unlucky how to say that.
To use for his bro.
Defending his bro.
Wow.
I need to...
Defend his...
How to say you're beautiful in Russian?
You're probably dead but I forgot.
Oh my god, how could you forget?
I don't know, I just...
I forgot a lot of things.
My memory is really bad.
Okay, what do you remember from the words Effect taught you?
Probably none.
Arigato.
That's not even Russian!
That's Japanese!
Oh, I thought you meant in general what he taught me.
I don't know.
Bro...
I bet Effect remembers everything you taught him.
I mean...
Nah, he never taught me anything.
Woah...
He didn't teach you anything?
Bro, that's not so rude to say.
That's not true.
What did you teach him?
Yeah, what did you teach him?
Bro...
I need to teach him myself, man.
He needs to teach himself German again.
Yeah...
Bro...
That's fucked, bro.
Yeah, teach us.
Yeah, teach me.
What does that mean?
Bad word, bad word.
Wait, you know it!
So you do remember!
Yeah, cause I said it almost every time.
That's why you know it.
Oh my god, man.
See?
You do remember your bro's language.
Give it to the producers, man.
My chat was like, don't repeat that!
That's a no!
No way!
No, it's not that bad.
It's like, it's alright.
Yeah, I could say worse.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm so cooked.
Unlucky, teach us a word.
Um...
Let me think.
Bro, I don't talk German anymore.
I don't even know how to talk German.
Don't you live in Austria?
Yeah.
What do you mean you don't use German anymore?
You literally live in a country that speaks the language.
I got one, I got one.
What does that mean?
What is that?
Sounds like a spell.
Yeah, what is he saying?
To be honest, I wouldn't even know how to translate that in English, to be honest.
I wouldn't even know.
Someone's like, oh dear.
I didn't know Doki was into that stuff.
It's Austrian.
It's Austrian, man.
Squirrel's tail?
What the fuck?
Tail of a squirrel?
What the fuck does that mean?
What?
Wait.
What the fuck does squirrel's tail...
...
What does that even mean?
I have no idea.
He just gave us a random word!
He just made it up.
From pros casting spells.
He's a fucking wizard.
Alright.
Bro became easier.
Bro become...
After that freaky shit.
Wait, we all know about Germans and their freakiness.
What is about the Austrians?
Are they...
Since Austria is Germany's neighbor, they are just as freaky.
Are you gonna match my freak?
This is why teams kill us early.
They don't want... they're scared.
My coughing is getting worse.
Oh no.
It's bad.
Got an ambulance.
Shocked.
We made them laugh.
It's getting worse.
Yeah.
It really does.
Holy fucking...
I bet you guys... I bet you guys... our team has the most content.
We are the content.
We are the content team.
It really does.
Yeah.
Are we also gonna win the tournament?
And if we don't, we burn... we sell effects as MVP.
Oh, you want burn?
I'm down for it.
Like, you know where he lives?
I mean, you said burn first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know where he lives?
Are we...
Okay.
Crazy.
I'm down.
Are we gonna do it?
Alright.
If we don't...
In fact, remember, if we don't win first, we're fucking heading over there.
Burning...
We'll stream it too.
What the fuck?
We'll stream the blibber.
I'll try to form on Zoom, bro.
Stop it.
He's gonna hate me.
Let's go kill EchoHQ.
Bro, let's go kill EchoHQ.
Yeah, okay.
For the live.
I need one who still have EVE.
I have a Havoc and a...
I'm not scared of you, V, though.
He's like a bitch and he's doing weird things over there.
They're not freaking yet.
Can you smoke?
I'm still gonna get headed.
Alright, I'm leaving already.
EchoHQ's already leaving too, but we can go.
Alright.
Smells like a...
It's making my jaw freak.
Yeah.
These guys are so sweaty.
I bet you they're hard calming and not even laughing at all.
I bet they're not even sick like us.
I hope not.
Yeah.
I bet you they're not even sick like us.
How dare they.
They should go outside right now and get sick.
I'm gonna sleep like a baby.
You're gonna fix your sleep schedule after this tournament?
It was already fixed.
That's the issue.
Like, I woke up at 8am every day in the past days.
Okay, don't worry.
You'll fix it now.
I'm a little... I'm like five seconds behind.
Yeah, it's fine.
I'm gonna hit the UV quick.
Okay.
I have a purple energy mag, but I don't know if I'm gonna need it.
I do.
I have a... I have an energy.
Yeah.
These guys are running, bro.
All three on each other.
They're like...
Yeah.
They're scared.
They wanna get in... Everybody's playing zone.
Fucking nerds.
Fucking nerds, man.
Yeah.
Fucking play BLGS if you're gonna play zone.
Oh, I'm saying... This is like only $100.
Come on, guys.
For a lot.
Okay.
True.
But all I'm saying...
I'm like, I know it's nothing for you.
Excuse me?
I'm not rich.
You can never be too rich.
That's the thing.
Oh, don't... Guys, remember.
They're EU, guys.
They have nothing in... No tournaments there.
Yeah, Sadoki's doing charity.
Oh, wait.
They just scanned.
Yeah.
Yep.
You still have that energy mag?
They can't hit shit.
Okay, they hit me.
Well, I was gonna sit up there.
I was like...
What were you getting shot at from right side?
That's... That should be Dragon's team then.
Raise one.
Yeah.
I don't know if you wanna fight them.
Yeah, because if Dragon's team might throw at us...
Whoa.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
I don't think... I just went there for the cash.
I don't think they're coming.
Dragon's not coming.
We can kill this.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
You have a zip, right?
They're all calling.
They are?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm saving a vehicle.
14, 19.
15.
I got 15.
Are we getting that cash to our left?
Yeah, we can.
I'm gonna grab this pick.
The ones you know.
We can go after them.
Yeah, in a second.
Let's go after them.
That's our prey.
We need to kill them.
We need that one kill, guys.
We're desperate.
There's a lot of light up here.
Yeah, I need some.
Okay.
Du gesicht.
Gesicht.
What?
Du gesicht.
What does that mean?
You're literally saying your face.
Your face.
What the fuck, man?
He's just admiring your face right now.
He wants you to turn the cam on for your stream so he can look at your face.
I'm up here.
Watch out.
Blank purple now.
Got purple too.
One guy on the right here.
Yeah.
We really have the best play.
They're back.
I'm batting quick.
Oh, he's getting shot at by a different team.
By a team to our right.
They're going left.
Oh yeah, one guy's late.
Bang.
Yeah, I'm shooting him.
In a second.
He already, like, crossed.
Yeah.
Bro, why are they all running away?
Dude, there's still 20 teams.
Everybody's, like, fucking cowards.
Yeah, I'm commencing him.
Some bats here.
They're going to hide.
They're all like, holy shit.
Oh,
there's a team here.
Where's the end, though?
It's like, uh...
I mean, they're playing bridge.
I don't think you want to fight bridge.
It's an iso 5 maybe here if you want to.
Yeah, let's go.
Alright.
Nobody's near us.
Like, bridge team is the closest team.
There's a charge rifle.
Is that dragon's team?
Nah, I doubt it.
I was going to say, because it's charge rifle.
Three kills with a charge rifle, you know?
That's how it works.
It's a Rampart.
Yeah, me too.
I'm hiding.
Can you smoke the...
I did.
Yeah.
Bang, open.
You can stay tip him here, maybe.
Yeah.
I'm dodging bangle.
I'm fucking...
I think.
Bro, my gun is not shooting.
I have.
Should be fine.
I'm roof.
I peek here?
I don't know if I can make it.
Yeah, my shield is not going to make it.
What?
I'm looking for you.
That thing is crazy, bro.
That's not good.
That's not good at all.
Can I even get to you?
No.
I think you just craft me.
Just leave on the way.
Okay.
Maybe...
Alright.
Just go craft there and rest.
Yeah, yeah.
I think you just craft me.
On the ping.
Yeah, yeah.
Holy shit.
Oh, that's...
I don't know if they're going to push me now because this is isolated.
No, no, no.
You're fine.
Holy shit.
You guys died so fast.
I died to a different team.
There was a guy next to me already.
That's unlucky.
It's fine.
You can easy craft there.
Yeah.
That's unlucky.
Unlucky.
Yeah.
I'm alive.
You're fine.
I got pinged so bad.
Yeah.
Bro, I got shielded the fuck out, bro.
I was like, what the f...
That shit was crazy.
You guys fucking died, died.
Now we have no loot, though.
So this is a little scary.
Yup.
Kind of chocked.
It's fine.
We have one fight and we're reviving.
I don't know if they...
Okay.
Our team didn't commit.
I think.
Yeah.
They're not fighting.
Walking off zone a little bit, though.
He's coming to charge rifle effect, I think.
Okay.
Damn.
Yeah.
I see the bank.
He does not like you.
I hear a car.
Car is...
Oh, wait.
Actually, no.
Sorry.
That's the zone.
Never mind.
I thought that was a car.
I know that because there was a car to our right.
So it, like, paranoid me.
Paranoia is hitting.
I'm hearing voices.
Same.
Every day.
Oh, shit.
You okay, man?
You got med kit?
I do.
Yeah.
This is my last med kit.
You have it?
Yeah.
You can syringe.
You have a lot of syringes now.
I have five.
I have four, but...
Yeah, I dropped...
I got...
I dropped the med kit.
It's my last one, but...
Any syringes?
Nope.
Oh, yeah.
I have four, so...
Bro.
Oh, yeah.
There's more.
There's more syringes here.
Yeah.
That's good.
All right.
Let's wait for the...
Loot bin reset as well.
Open every bin here.
I don't know if they're already open.
I got two shields now because of that bitch with charge rifle.
Damn.
Fuck that guy.
Yeah, he's just shooting.
Extended sniper mag here.
Level two.
I just don't know if there's just, like, people on the other side.
Can we hit the UV, maybe?
Again?
You cannot?
You can only get once, right?
I hit that already?
When did I hit that?
When we found that team.
What the hell?
The reason why we chased that team.
Skippity cooked, man.
Yeah.
Skippity cooked you guys so hard.
Well, where is it with the zone?
Bro, I just fucking...
I have bat.
Do you want the bat?
Fine.
Okay.
Oh, you got your bin here.
Can you smoke?
Yeah, we got to be conservative with our loot.
I mean, can we not play in this gap here with Newcastle?
Yeah, sure.
Then go out late?
Maybe?
And then free people with a zipline or something on the left?
All right.
I'm heading over.
Watch out from here.
Yeah.
Someone close here.
I think there's somebody in the gap already.
Come.
I'm here.
Close.
I hear them.
Yeah.
They're right next to you.
I'm peeking.
Yeah.
Well cucked.
I'm pushing.
I'm peeking.
Cucked.
Oh, I got a shield here.
Okay.
We gotta watch our back though.
Yeah.
Looked at it?
I'm looting.
Yeah.
So many bats and there's MET kits too.
I have three...
I have six bats.
Does anyone want them?
There's four here.
I need a MET kit without.
We just hold here, okay?
Let's hold here out until last second and then we just play.
Okay.
Like, there just may be free people left or right.
Sorry, that's...
No, no team...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I need a bat, I need a bat.
I'm out to the zipper.
I'm going to ult here?
I'm going to ult now.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm a bitch bro.
Oh shit, I lost my other thing here.
Yeah, you can rest with me.
Can I dress you?
Oh no!
Such a bitch man.
I think there's a mob in the middle.
I'm going to double check.
I'm checking.
No, there's an evac.
No, they only have evac.
I saw one.
Evac ulted?
Yeah.
They're not coming though.
Are we in?
The respawn on the left is on the left, right?
Yeah, but I don't know if we could get that.
Yeah, you're in.
Team down there, we're not safe.
Wait, look bro.
Look at this.
Can you go left?
Come, come, come.
Yeah, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Oh, ready?
No smokes, no smokes.
They're fighting, that's why we need to go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can you come?
Yeah, I'm shielding and I'm heading over now.
Watch out the logon.
I have Q, I have Q.
Nice, just go, just go.
Let's zip up.
Need to watch out on the res though.
Just going top too.
Let's go.
Q, on top, full team.
Bangalore.
Bangalore, Bangalore low.
It's only two up there.
Yeah, oh.
I'm batting.
You too.
100.
I have the bat, the bat.
I'm tanking, I have to tank this.
Yeah, they're looking at it.
I'm dropping.
On us below.
On the right side.
Yeah, I'm getting shot from behind too.
We're dead.
We're all dead.
No!
Yeah, we should...
Yeah, that res was too risky.
That was my bad.
I just forgot about the fucking bridge team.
That res was so fucked.
Oh my god, I fucking forgot this bridge team was like switch angles for me dude.
Top 17 bro, like we cannot fight, they were just running away from us.
Yeah.
Yeah, when I died I realized that we were the first team to kill someone.
It was top 20 when we killed that team and then it was 19.
Nobody wants to fight.
It's actually crazy dude.
We just play zone again or what?
Nah, we need to be more faster.
Okay.
We need to take care from Ekko.
Yeah, let's just wait quick and then we'll kill Ekko.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
That's crazy, everybody just does... everybody's are pussies.
Running a lot away, I don't know why.
Yeah, I had so many... I have... oh my god, so many different people shot me.
One, two, three, four, five.
Five, five... wait, one, two, three, four, five, five, six.
That's a new Pathfinder.
Oh my god.
I had six different people fight me, holy shit.
I think it's just... it'll just be like that.
It's okay, we got two games.
It's things like my brain is just not working.
I'm overheating.
Oh no.
No, don't overheat.
Think!
I might be getting... I might be getting fever out here right now, can't lie.
No!
I thought you were getting better!
I thought so too.
What happened?
You were supposed to recover.
Yeah, I know.
I was supposed to.
Sadgers.
What happened to you?
Life.
I'm gonna grab a snack.
Oh shit.
Okay, we have two more games.
Two more?
No, we're watching that team.
Bro, it was that team that we fucked.
I literally made this Bangalow 1HP so many times.
Yikes.
No way.
And they were the team that was running away from us.
Yeah.
That's unlucky.
Those little bitches.
Alright, we're back.
We were just unlucky as we were stuck between two teams when we won a res.
Nobody let us res.
Everybody was so mean to us.
Nope.
He freaked too close to the sun.
He needs to stop.
We gotta lower our freaking level if we want to survive.
We gotta lower the freak levels.
Between three teams, a rock and a hard place.
Yeah.
As long as we do well in the next two games, we should be okay.
We might get top three.
I mean, we're doing really well for throwing a lot of games.
Yeah.
We need to get another banger.
Yeah, we just need one big banger and then we're good to go.
We can relax.
Someone's like, you're just not freaking enough.
No, don't tone it down, you gotta commit now.
I think this team... I think the team we're watching might win.
Yeah, it's uh, the first place team.
Oh, is that... is that Dragon's team?
I think so.
Oh, it is... it is...
Yeah, yeah, it's Dragon's team.
Your play's so sweaty!
Turned off your brain!
For real.
Turn it off!
The worst is just getting to play.
Just to wait.
Waiting is so hard.
But it's entertaining if they're sweaty.
No, I'm the main character.
Our team should be the only team sweaty.
That's how it should go.
Alright, now entertain three people's chats.
No, actually you guys should entertain me.
Why am I entertaining?
I'm sick here.
I should be entertained.
Honestly, I think it's just the fact that like...
The fact that like...
We're just too freaky for this game.
No, we're freaky.
You're the streamer, bro.
Well, I want to reverse it.
I'm sick.
So like, I should get like a...
I should get like a plus one.
A plus one chat entertains the streamers.
I do.
I'm taking medic...
That's why I've been using the bathroom a lot.
I've been hydrating a lot too.
So that's why I've been using the bathroom a lot.
Because I need to fucking hydrate from all the...
From trying to, you know, replenish my liquids.
I don't know.
I don't know why I'm doing this right now.
It's too much to handle.
Yeah, we're just too much.
We're too much to handle.
It's crazy though that everybody's running and not fighting.
Which is understandable.
Like, this is like a tournament format.
So like, people...
I really, really want to win.
Like, I want to win.
But, like, not that.
Not that.
Like, I want to win.
But I'm too sick right now to have that feeling.
I'm too sick to feel that right now at a more intense feeling.
I'm just... I want to survive.
That's all I feel right now.
I just... I want to survive.
Number one.
They got 13th with second.
GG's.
I think they win.
Oh yeah, Monsoon's team or...
Is it Monsoon?
No, enemies.
I forgot Monsoon couldn't make it, so enemies...
Yeah, I think they're going to be first place.
Oh hey, Skippity!
Your favorite!
And Skippity is third!
They're farming too, what the f...
The team is golden.
Oh my god, go Skippity!
I wore it.
And it said it's going to be delivered in like 50 minutes.
And I got it in 20.
Nice.
Yay!
I mean, not nice.
Not nice.
Yeah, yeah!
They're late!
That's the first time when I'm not happy with the first delivery.
Oh my god.
Bro.
What?
You're not even EU!
You guys don't need it!
Dragon, you don't need it!
You're not EU!
Give some love to the EU!
Give some love to the EU players!
They need that $175!
Damn.
Look, guys.
If I... If we...
I don't think we're going to cash up to them, but...
But if we somehow make it to first place, I will donate my prize winnings to Effect and...
Effect and Unlucky.
I thought you were going to set the choice.
Yeah.
It is charity.
It is.
But it is.
It is charity.
What do you mean?
I'm helping the EU...
The EU talents out.
One...
One donation at a time.
Oh my god.
The EU pros charity.
Exactly.
We're here to help the EU pro charity.
Alright, I'm going to use the bathroom again.
Alright, entertaining my chat.
And Unlucky's chat.
Where the fuck is Unlucky?
Is he back in the bathroom?
I guess.
He's on the sticky time again.
Oh my god.
Twice in a row?
Jeez.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Bro.
I, that ass, fell asleep on the fucking couch in the fucking living room.
Understandable.
I, dude...
Oh my god.
I woke up.
I was like...
And I'm like...
Wait, the game's not ready?
I'm like, oh shit, what the fuck is going on?
I was so confused.
I was like, oh my god, okay.
It's endgame still.
I actually passed out like two minutes for like a grandpa and I came back and I felt like... I don't know.
Did it feel like ten hours?
Yes.
It was bad.
Bro, what the fuck, man?
Well, I got my food, like...
He said delivery's gonna be in fifteen minutes and I got it in twenty.
Oh, you ordered food at this time?
Yeah.
Yeah, bro.
I was like...
Yeah, I'm gonna order pizza and watch some anime.
Mhm.
And I got it now when we have two more games, man.
Why did we vote for the seventh one, man?
Yeah, I don't know who voted for that one.
I personally only voted for it because I thought the first one doesn't count.
Same, to be honest.
I was like, nah, let's play more.
I don't want to regret it.
I'm just so cooked, like...
It's just so bad.
I think it's like...
Mechanics-wise and shit, I'm calm, you know?
But brain-wise, I'm so cooked.
Like, even this peak where I got killed by the British team, it was so obvious.
I'm just cooked.
I can't think.
You're just not thinking?
Yeah.
It's alright.
We'll have Effect IGL for us.
That's... that's not the best thing you could ask for.
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's not... We'll have... Is Hakkas like, awake right now?
Could we call him to coach?
Let's call Hakkas to coach us right now.
There's no rules against it.
Get his ass in here.
Yeah, get his ass in here and coach.
Fucking unk.
I can't even breathe, man.
Breathe.
I mean, there's no rules against, like, outside coaching while we play.
Damn.
All I'm saying...
I think if we win first, we could have a chance to get second.
If we have one first place game.
Yeah, plus it.
It's okay.
Sounds so easy, right?
Yeah, so easy.
I mean, you guys have done it before.
Like, you could do it again.
You could do it again.
I believe.
Should I hop on Nagi?
Or Valk?
Should I actually play Valk?
I feel like I should.
Do it.
If you do Valk, should I do Bangalore then?
You could.
Yeah, you can just fuck Newcastle.
Yeah, fuck the Newcastle.
Alright.
We're not playing zone for the Wolves, you know?
Okay.
And then this next game, we're gonna get so fucked over because we had no Newcastle.
Yeah.
It's gonna be like the most open area and then we're... Yeah, I'm like...
Yeah bro, we need a wall, dude.
We have to kill a team for their wall.
Like, that's the only... True, by the team...
That game, we won the Newcastle.
Yeah, true, true.
We take their walls.
We take their...
Yeah.
It's fine.
This is it.
This is... Don't worry.
We figure out...
Now we know our actual comp.
Now...
Now we know our real comp.
I'm just playing fucking Wraith, dude.
Good luck.
Yes.
Oh, you're gonna get Wraith?
What?
I like how Effect doesn't even respond back.
He's just...
He's just... Yeah, that's what I said.
Are we actually playing two game... Are we actually playing more than one game?
I don't even know.
I guess we are.
Yeah.
Huh?
I guess we are.
We're playing... So there's two more games.
This game and the game after.
Yeah.
We got this, I believe.
We just need one really good game and then we can fucking fuck her off.
It's calm.
It's just $100.
It's a lot.
A lot of money we're playing for here.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
We got this.
Fuck.
No pressure.
You guys already used up all the money you guys won from Esports Champion?
Like, what happened?
Bro, we don't even have the money yet.
You guys don't have the money yet?
What?
No.
How long does it take to be sent?
I don't know.
Why?
Oh, shit.
Okay, guys.
Guys, this is why they need this.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't have any money.
Like, I don't have any money in my bank account at this current.
Like...
Wait, actually?
I generally have 30 euros in my account right now.
What?
Guys.
Guys, okay.
This is their Twitch, guys.
Shout out to my teammates.
This is their Twitch.
This is...
Yo, let the money float in.
Guys, this is their Twitch, guys.
AlphaTru is looking bad out here too, bro.
Too much charity.
That shit getting abused.
Oh my god.
This is why, this is why they need a...
We need a win, guys.
This is why we need a win.
I need that money to win.
He needs that money for the bank account.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Are you guys okay?
I'm not.
Okay, I know you're not okay.
But what about you, Effect?
Like, I know there's a lot of stuff going on there.
But like, what about you, Effect?
Are you okay?
I'm okay.
You don't seem... Are you?
Are you the...
Are you actually the... Are you okay?
No, I'm okay.
Thank you for that ASMR.
I feel better.
Oh my god.
Bro, this is your teammate.
I know.
I have to deal with it.
Yo.
Damn, he's giving that to you for free.
People need a tier 3 sub for that.
Yeah, bro.
Come on.
People pay for that, dude.
I'm just giving that shit from here.
ASMR.
ASMR sickness.
Bro, I'm trying to be that deep e-boy.
Deep e-boy?
Deep e-boy.
Alright, wait, wait.
I can't even.
Yo, what's up?
What's up, man?
Wait, come on.
Keep going.
Are we locked or what?
Bro, nah.
We're locked in shoddy.
Alright, we'll be playing now.
What am I playing?
Rift?
I'm playing Bangalore, right?
Bro, I think Rift is the key.
I'm not kidding, bro.
Alright.
It might be.
You ready or what?
Yep.
Alright.
I'm the worst racer.
Wait, what?
You don't say that after.
Okay, this is gonna be really... we either get knocked out first or we actually gonna make it.
We're gonna win it all.
We're gonna win it all, dude.
Yeah, we're dropping a 50 bomb right now.
Let's go.
Right here, we get that 50 bomb.
Just give me the toilet.
Doki with 20 kills, is he?
Alright, we push Ekko now, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You ready?
Loot up!
Yo, we stop Loot Puffs.
We stop Loot Puffs, I'm like...
Yeah, Efek got super hyped up after that.
I have no Logra, I loot nothing.
Oh, what?
Yes!
Yeah, seven games!
Yeah, we need that seventh game!
We need that?
Do you see we need that bro?
Oh, we don't, we gotta win now or we serve?
We need that seventh game though.
No, we don't, we don't.
What do you mean?
We're like fourth place, what do you mean?
It's fine, we win now with like 700 million points.
Yeah, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's how math works, by the way.
That's how math works.
That's how I get told in school.
You're saying the teachers lied to me?
Yes, Austrian teachers, maybe.
Ah, bro, I'm fucking ups.
Bro, you're barely even alive, I don't think you can do math right now.
Bro, actually, that's how you sound like.
What the fuck do you mean?
You sound like a fucking guy, like...
No way!
I can hear, I can hear your cough drops right now.
It's like fucking...
Why do we have zone?
Bro!
What do you mean?
Oh, bro, this is crazy.
Anyways, can we... in fact, we have zone.
Okay.
And?
And what do you want us to do with that?
I don't know, bro.
What do you want us to do with that information?
Okay.
I don't know, bro, whip it up.
I don't know.
All right, I'm heading... I'm ready heading over.
Ready heading over?
Sounds...
I need, like, a long range.
I have alternator eva ready.
What if I hit Kennen?
Bro...
He might be behind them.
Elas, Elas, Elas, Elas.
Do it, do it.
I think it works.
Bro...
Okay.
Because if they're there, I just couldn't come back, you know what I'm saying?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't see them at all.
You see them?
No.
I'm gonna go to...
Oh, I see this Kennen, this Kennen.
They know.
Fuck.
They know now.
They know you're at the Kennen.
Hit that shit, hit that shit, hit that shit.
Do it, do it, do it, do it.
All right, all right, all right.
I'm already there.
I'm...
Well, I'm not there, but okay.
On the roof?
You can fuck this guy on the roof.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm heading over.
You guys...
Yeah.
Fuck this guy on the left of the roof.
I'm, like, ten seconds behind you guys.
You guys were so fast.
I know where he is.
Where is he?
He was here.
Like, somewhere this direction.
Okay.
We're inside the ring.
Got the position on base.
That one...
Over here?
Yeah.
I smoked for myself.
I'm gonna slide down here.
I'm heading over to you.
I don't know where the...
Oh, there.
One on the right.
I'm almost...
Flash, flash here.
Okay, okay.
I'm healing.
One of me in front of me here.
Okay.
I'm healing now.
He's one.
Dead.
Cracked, cracked, cracked.
90.
Yeah, I'm pushing him.
Okay.
Go for him.
I cracked him.
Fuck him up.
Eat his ass.
Left one on UAV.
Munch, munch, munch, munch, munch.
I'm scrying in circles.
Five months soon.
Hey.
Whoa.
Nice.
This is not BM, guys.
Balloon coming in from pylon.
Watch out.
Okay.
Where's the last guy?
Since we potentially have zone here.
Yeah, balloon flanked us.
He got broke.
Yeah.
Okay.
He's gonna play here.
What in the sigma?
I'm just gonna grab stuff.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I might come here.
Watch out.
Yeah, you're getting shot from Munch soon.
We need to watch out.
Okay.
Yeah.
Watch out.
They're the first place team for a reason.
Yeah.
What if we turn around?
Fuck them up.
No.
Ah, shit, bro.
I got the wrong...
Let's go.
I forgot big alert.
I got the wrong upgrade.
I got the wrong...
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
Okay.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
They might come though.
It's okay.
I get all fast now.
Yeah.
So far though.
Yep.
They're not real.
Did we kill the full team or...
At least two.
Did we kill all three?
Two.
Okay.
Cannon.
They're going to take a movie.
Fuck.
Two guys on cannon.
One's cracked.
Skippy died.
Trying to nade it?
We're not putting on a bang.
Okay.
But she's like with him.
Yeah.
She's far left.
What a nade, bro.
I'm so ass.
I'm trying to get across.
Okay.
Marking on them effect.
They're all together now.
Big dead.
So much damage.
One down.
Ah fuck.
That's all you got.
Yeah.
You're by yourself.
There's three on that cannon.
Whoa effect.
I got a ten.
Oh my God.
One HP.
I got a look.
I'm running over.
Let's run.
One HP.
Okay.
No, he's mine!
Okay, Skippity and LanderRotate are dead!
They're dead, so...
No, we're off, baby, we're off!
Let's go, that's our game!
Yes, sir!
Bro, I swear, I haven't shot my gun.
I shot my gun one time, and that was from that air thing.
You guys are so fucking fast.
You're so fast, I can't keep up!
Watch our back as well.
Okay.
I'm going to leave Rotate to us.
Dragon's team has been playing zone this entire time.
Wait, the Bangalore is here in front of us.
Let's go over there.
I got zipped on, bro, literally in my face too, guys.
Yo, yo, we're heading over, I'm heading over.
Cracked one.
Half, half, half, half.
One is B.
I'm trying to...
What the fuck, I got stuck on that tree.
I'm heading over to you.
Here in front of me.
Two behind this rock, one on the left.
Careful, team behind this rock.
Cracked her!
Nice.
I'm graffling the guy on the right.
I cracked the... I think that was the catalyst that got knocked.
Yeah.
I heard a grapple.
Cracked him, cracked him.
Left, on your left.
I'm dead.
Cracked the two.
I'm thirsting the catalyst.
I don't know if I can...
I'm smoking that.
Can I even get you?
Maybe here.
No, I died.
Play your life, play your life.
Don't care about us.
Okay, we might got a little too overzealous.
I threw, man.
I threw.
I did so bad.
Yo, am I even crawling away?
I believe in unlucky to be the best rat.
You just have to rat so hard that you win.
Nah, I'm getting frustrated by two teams now.
Just rat.
Survive.
I don't want to rat.
No!
We need these points!
We killed Skippity!
How many points?
How many do we need?
We need, like, second place or third place.
Yeah, but how many points?
How far are we?
We need... Okay, I'll look, I'll look.
We need... We need 20 points.
Easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just rat.
You can get my banner for sure, bro.
I have Moby, bro.
Yeah, but be safe, though.
TP, I could, but I have no TP.
He is close to you.
You can even Q away.
In fact, I swear to God, if he fucking...
Oh wait, get in zone, maybe.
I only got one med kit.
Do you have meds on you, Effect?
I do.
Oh, there's people, there's people, there's people there.
Yeah, the rest.
Go for it, go for it.
Yes, sir.
They're fighting.
They're going Echo.
They're rezzing, just leave.
Just don't play cocky there.
There might be a team up top, so careful.
Yeah.
I think you might as well just rezz here instead.
I have Moby as well.
What if I just rezz here?
Yeah, yeah, just saying, rezz here.
But, like, not in front of everybody.
No, there's balloon left.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I have TP soon.
Use your mobile.
Use your Moby.
Yeah, I think go, I guess I'm open now.
Go back, go back, go back.
What about that team to the left?
Oh, zip on you.
I know.
I have TP, I'm 82.
Okay, I'm gonna, I'm scared.
I'm scared, I'm looking away.
I have TP soon.
Fuck.
They broke the balloon.
I think you just chill here in zone, you know?
And then rezz.
I'm going Barra.
Cool.
I can't look.
You call him, maybe?
Yeah, call Moby here.
Just call Moby, yeah.
And then we can go loot Coastal, easy.
Yeah.
I don't need my medkit, by the way.
I think we should go Pilot, to be honest.
You see Box in front of you.
Yeah, I know.
We can kill the spiders, too, if we're...
meds.
But we might get held.
Yeah, I know, that's why I don't wanna...
We can't do spiders.
I think I want medkit, that's why.
I don't wanna see them.
They're shooting here, but I don't know what's going on.
It's fine, it's fine.
We're good, we're good.
Nobody's there.
On the hill, on the chill, only one guy.
By the way, you can take it.
160 bullets.
Only saw one guy over there.
Oh!
You can loot that box.
I'm gonna go to Unlucky.
Taking a different path.
Yeah, it's a full team in Pilot, I think.
Maybe we can fight them, even.
Come, come.
I'm good to fight.
They're sitting in the corner, I don't think they know about this.
Yeah, come, I'll give you meds.
Yeah, I know.
I'll take the shield cells, you can take the bats.
You can take the rest, you can take all this.
They're literally in front of us.
On my ping, they're just sitting there.
They're bang ulting?
I don't know what the fuck they're bang ulting.
They're slid down now.
Oh, charging, yeah, we're charging.
Yeah, let's kill this team.
Yeah, sit down, come.
Staying up here?
I'm here.
I think they went mid.
There's someone here, I think.
Inside, inside, inside.
On my door, all three.
They're gonna put a wall.
Yeah, they put a wall.
Oh, they fucked, oh yeah.
Yeah, I know.
I cracked, I cracked, Newcastle.
Newcastle's up.
I'm chilling, fighting.
Thing alert low.
Just heal, just heal.
I'm healing.
I have to heal too.
Yeah, there's a team behind us.
I'm backing out, backing out.
I'm backing out a little bit, yeah.
Nice job, they're resing.
Gonna go back in.
This other team behind us might push us though.
I got the fin, I got the fin, I got the fin.
Yeah, I'm picking, I'm picking.
I'm looking behind.
Careful, careful, careful.
Don't get knocked, don't get knocked, don't get knocked.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
All dead, all dead, all dead.
Watch tree, watch tree.
Behind us, behind us.
I'm full HP, we can go in here if we need to.
Yeah, it's fine.
Alright, we full heal, I think we're just gonna fight tree.
We're next, and then we just move over, no?
I have... do you guys need bats?
I have bats.
I have bats too.
Ah, fuck man, I'm moving.
I think there's so many teammates in pylon to do that, to be honest, fuck me.
There's an ult XL.
I got an ult XL for us.
Let's reach the MSS quick.
Yeah, I think we have to fight either tree.
I think it's gonna be hard, because there's so many...
This team is a lot too...
We can play water for now, we know we're chilling.
We don't have to rush.
Wait, nobody hide?
We can go hide, we can go hide.
We have to force the fight though.
Yeah, yeah, let's go.
No, 75, I can ult XL right now.
I'm ult XL-ing.
I can get it right now.
Yeah, but they will be in front of us.
Maybe we can TP past them?
I have it, I have it.
I'm with you.
You need to smoke, you need to smoke here.
I almost cracked one.
Oh shit, okay.
Maybe rest, maybe rest right now.
Okay.
I'm smoking, I'm double smoking.
Ours is ours, it's ours.
Can you rest again?
Yeah, yeah.
My smoke might run out here though.
I hit somebody.
I think it's not that good, no.
Oh, it's ambush.
Yeah.
Just stay alive, just stay alive.
Play your life, play your life.
Because they might push up.
We'll look, we'll look.
Here, here.
Just play it to rest.
We're gonna fight that, we're good.
You kill us, you kill us, you kill us.
I can, I can block it if I have to.
Sure.
Yeah, there's a team right above us.
And there's a team north-east.
Here, here, careful.
Can you come here?
Yeah, I'm trying to.
I'm bleeding out though.
Close, close, close.
No, no, no, don't rest, don't rest.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
I'm blocking as much as I can.
Just get that.
Oh.
I'm gonna try my best.
Oh, I'm body blocking as much as I could.
Oh, nice!
I swapped it.
It was pinged.
I swapped it, man.
It was fucking pinged.
Nice job.
Bro, my grapple fucked up.
Yeah.
Aww.
Yeah, we got pushed in our backs too.
So that was unlucky.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
That's why I got knocked.
Because I was rezzing Effect and then I got pushed in the back so I couldn't finish the rezz.
Okay, I am voting for...
How did the team...
Why did the team come to our back?
Because they had... they saw us.
I think they saw us rotate so they um...
They mirrored us.
We got killed by the backshots?
Or... no, no.
Don't say that.
I mean, this was the comp.
We just got fucked over by our backs.
It would have been so good if there wasn't everywhere a team, bro.
The thing is...
How did...
Why did the team not end up fighting?
Like the team who gave you backshots.
Why did they not fight?
They did.
They fought the team to the right and then there was a team...
They knocked us.
Then there was...
Then there was a little gap, maybe I could have rezzed.
I think if you like, insta-take TP after I placed it, and then I stay there and then I can rezz.
That's the only time I can rezz, maybe.
Yeah, I think so too.
Because later on I couldn't rezz because of the top team.
No...
I can't believe they fucking pushed us.
Fuck me, man.
Okay, we still have one more game.
We still have...
one more.
Did we even get placement points for it?
I don't even know what place...
What place did we get?
We got one point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't believe it.
The backshots.
The backshots doing work, baby.
It's okay.
We got Skippity out.
We got Skippity and the...
What was it?
The rotate.
So there's still a chance.
We might...
It might be over for them.
Yep.
That's all we need.
At least we don't have to wait too long.
It's like...
Whoa, five teams left?
Not too long, though.
Bro, I think we played them wrong.
Like, I think we should have...
I think she should have popped the Excel so we get bangled.
And then we hold our back, you know, the stone clothes.
And then we just play in with...
Yeah.
Nah, the reason like we lost it is because I died and I fucked up my grapple.
You know, like I just want it open.
If I don't do that, we're chilling, bro.
I would have had an off angle.
Yeah, I couldn't smoke in time, too, because I was a bit behind, guys.
Because I was ult-excelling.
Yeah, I think if you didn't die, it would be an easy wipe as well.
Because I just cracked both of them on the red as well.
Yeah, that would have been so easy.
And then I ulted the right.
Now we know that both of you guys aren't Pathfinder players.
Nah, that's a path.
Don't put me in that one.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god, the backshot.
Oh my god, and they killed...
Yeah, they killed the backshots.
Holy shit.
It's crazy.
Oh, they are patient.
Everybody's playing Rampart.
It's so cringe.
It's too much.
I think we only died to Rampart.
Once.
For real.
In the first game.
Oh yeah, that's true.
All our deaths were Rampart.
Holy shit.
Where's the last...
Oh, the last team is to the farm, right?
Oh, they got Devo.
That's fucked.
Oh my god.
They're coming in to backshot too.
They're heading in.
Which team's gonna win?
I think it's...
Oh shit.
Not drunk ass association.
These are all new teams.
Because we killed off the two...
Because we killed off the top teams.
These are all...
The remaining teams are like new teams now.
We saved the lobby.
We up.
We saved the lobby from the terrorizers.
That's us.
We did that.
We cleared the way.
So that more...
So that more people can have fun.
And then we purposely died early.
So more teams can have a chance.
Kind of.
Yeah.
That's our plan, right?
Yes.
Yeah, we took those backshots on purpose.
Yeah, exactly.
I love getting backshots.
Are we not playing one more?
Are we?
I don't know.
It says yes.
The votes were... Did you guys voted?
I voted.
Yeah.
I took my vote off of...
Yeah, yeah.
I took my vote off.
Should be one more game.
Everyone said GG's and not living.
That's the best part.
Do we vote again?
No.
We keep going.
What place are we right now?
We're fourth.
We're fourth, but if we get a really good game, we could be second or third.
Because Loot, Land, Rotate is so help-head that like...
I don't know.
Unless they get eliminated so early.
Hmm.
How much points for third?
Third is 64.
We're 51.
Damn.
I think we called it.
Bro, I don't think there's a chance for anyone to catch up.
Oh, people are voting nay.
I think that's last game then.
Nah.
Over 30 yes to work.
What?
You need to have 30 people to say yes.
Oh, shit.
Where's the fucking thingy again?
Can I invite people in to vote yes?
Bro, my pizza is gonna be mad at you.
Bro, you could eat your pizza right now.
I don't want to, bro.
Why am I gonna eat it with a fork?
Bro, in fact, if we win this game, we get prize money.
Yeah, bro.
Bro, do you not want prize money?
Take that no away.
In fact, take that no away and then put that yeah in.
I'm watching it right now.
Take that nay.
Take that no away right now and make it a tie.
Okay.
Yeah, there we go.
Peer pressure works, guys.
Peer pressure works.
I'm so stupid.
I don't find the voting thingy.
Oh, is that the restart request?
Just vote...
Yes, we put yay.
I hear.
Unlucky, you better put yay because it's...
Take that nay away, in fact.
Unlucky, unvote that.
We need it to be...
Unvote that right now.
I'm fucking dying.
Bro, in fact, that's a no.
In fact, take that away.
Put that shit right off.
We need third place.
In fact, get your ass out of there.
We need third.
We need third, in fact.
I need money, bro.
In fact, we need money for the bro.
I have it on yeah, bro.
I'm just spamming nay now.
Just don't.
If we spam nay, they're gonna put nay.
In fact, get your no off of there.
I'm getting fake accounts in here.
In fact, I swear to god, in fact, get that nay out there.
I'm doing nothing.
I'm not touching my mouse.
I swear to god.
If I see your hand...
If I open your stream and I see that on nay, I swear to god.
Click on my emoticon.
The last one.
I swear to god, in fact.
We need that pizza.
We need that $75.
I need money, bro.
Come on.
Come on, bro.
We need that money.
Bro!
Okay, I don't need it, but like...
Unlucky needs that money.
That's what I'm saying.
I need money.
Guys, do it for your homie.
DM everyone who said no.
DM everyone.
DM everybody.
Everybody that says no.
I swear to god.
You guys don't want fun?
Nah,
it's going down, bro.
It went from 27 to 24.
Was that your fault?
Definitely.
How dare you.
Help the sick.
Exactly.
You gotta help.
Donate to the sick right now.
How could you do this to us?
Oh my god.
It's literally so close.
We need like...
We need like 2 more people to vote.
Yay.
We literally need 2 more people.
I don't understand why they don't want to play another game.
It's like literally just one more.
There's 3 people left.
There's 3 people left who need to vote.
No, 2.
We need 2 people to vote.
I will create another account.
Join it and then vote.
What if I change my second?
No, no.
Don't you dare.
I'm gassing like everyone in the chat right now.
What are you saying?
What did you say?
I don't want that.
I don't even know what you said.
Oh, here you go.
I see Yahoo is on.
Do it for EU.
Do it for Unlucky.
Bro, he's been so unlucky.
He needs this.
Yeah.
Bro, Unlucky just wants to play more.
Do it for him.
He got you.
I can't believe it.
Now they're voting less.
Unlucky, what did you do?
They took away their votes afterwards.
Blame it all on Unlucky.
They actually took away the votes after.
Fuck, man.
I tried my best.
Alright.
GG's, guys.
That was fun, though.
It was.
If I wasn't so crooked, it would've been more fun.
We definitely sold a lot.
It's okay.
Do you guys want to do a team again next time?
In Revenge Arc?
Yeah.
That was really fun.
Next time, if I get another invite to a tournament, we run it back.
We run it back and then we'll...
Let's get a hold of them, bro.
Yeah, and then we'll both not be sick.
And then Unlucky's mind won't be super cooked.
And he won't be too freaky.
He was so distracted.
That's my freak.
That's crazy.
Yeah, he was so distracted and so freaked out.
I am.
What can I say?
I'm just locked.
Yeah.
Yeah, you've been too fucking freaky.
But that was fun, though.
I had so much fun playing.
I hope you guys sleep well.
And Unlucky, you get better soon.
Like, overall.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much, Steve.
Thank you.
GG's, guys.
GG's.
Bye-bye.
Let's play again next time.
Run it back.
Yes, sir.
Bye-bye.
That was fun!
That was a lot of fun.
Like, I'm surprised how well we did.
For, like, how fucking fucked up we were.
We were so fucked up.
Overall, as a team.
In terms of, like, not like we had really good chemistry, but, like, we were just, like, we were sick and, like, we were fucking around so much.
Yeah.
Both sick and freaky.
Yeah, yeah.
That game where they fucking carried when I was in the back.
Yeah, we were trolling so much.
We literally had two games with zero points.
We had two games with zero points because we were getting way too freaky.
We were like, you know what?
Two of my teammates with 200 ping, let's fucking push that shit.
Let's...
Let's fucking do it.
And then we got...
We got too... We were so...
We got backshots like crazy there.
Yeah, yeah.
What could go wrong?
I think if the last game...
If the last game we played more...
Like, a lot of the tryhard teams were playing so fucking safe with zones and everything.
And then my team, we were just fucking... We were just fucking around.
Like, going after people.
Like, I was trying to be like, guys, slow down, please.
Guys, I'm fine.
I'm like, trying to run over.
I'm like, please.
Please slow down.
I need... I need... I can't keep up.
We're playing a different game.
Yeah, we were... We were just killing... Our team was just here to kill.
Not for... We were not doing position... No IGL.
Bro, we literally... We were playing the tournament as if...
As if it was a pub.
I swear.
This did not feel like a tournament.
We were just playing a game as if it was a fucking pub.
Like...
So true.
We were not... We were not playing tournament style.
But it was fun though.
It was really fun playing.
It was really fun playing with them.
Even though we were just... It was literally pub style.
But it was so fucking fun though.
Playing it pub-like.
And...
Because we were not thinking.
We were not thinking at all.
Because I was like, oh guys, this doesn't seem right.
And then they were already there.
So I was like, okay.
But they were like, they were like, we're gonna dump... We're gonna kill that team.
And then that team.
And I'm just like, I don't know guys.
I don't know if that's... I feel like maybe we should stop.
They're like, no.
We're gonna still go on.
And then we died.
I'm like, okay.
I was like, okay.
But...
We're just running it down.
Full W key.
It was worth it.
I mean, the fact that we got...
We got so many points.
Even though...
Even though we had two games with zero points.
It's actually... It's been fun.
Um...
I'm sorry.
I'm so sick.
I'm so fucking...
I'm so fucked up right now.
Um...
I'm gonna message the babysitter to take care of dad for another extra day.
Cause I was supposed to get him back tomorrow.
But like, I still need that extra day to like, recover.
Cause I'm like, I'm so fucked up right now.
Um...
We still were gonna try and do Silent Hill 2.
The reviews came out overall positive.
I was so surprised.
Cause everybody was like, dooming over...
Everybody was like, dooming about, um...
About the, uh...
The, um...
The Silent Hill 2.
But like, there's so many overall good reviews.
Cause I know people are like, Yeah, but this review site tends to have not good reviews.
But, um...
It was overall very positive.
And like, multiple websites.
Like, multiple reviewers.
Multiple, uh...
People were saying it actually was pretty good.
For, um...
For a remake.
Cause there was a lot of doomers.
So I'm really excited to try out Silent Hill 2 now.
I'm very scared because I never...
The first time I ever tried Silent Hill 2, It was me with my friend.
And we bought the remastered, like the trilogy remastered.
And then we literally tried to play Silent Hill 3 For like, three sec...
For like, the mall part.
And then we closed the game and went to play Epic Mickey.
Like, Epic Mickey 2.
Cause we were like, this is too scary.
It was in the day.
And then I had the controller.
And my friend was watching me try to play it.
And then we closed the game.
After we got to the mall scene.
Like, where they all turn into monsters in the mall scene.
And then we closed the game and played Epic Mickey 2.
Cause we were like, this is too much.
This is...
Um...
But yeah.
I hope that...
I hope it'll be really fun.
I honestly hope that Silent Hill 2 will be very enjoyable.
Anyway guys!
I'm gonna head off now.
I am tired.
I'm gonna rest up a little bit until 9pm.
The release day.
I'm gonna...
But it was really fun to play with Effect and Unlucky.
I had an amazing time with both of them.
I'm glad they started opening up more.
And like, not being super serious.
And just fucking around, you know.
That's what I like about interacting with new people.
And just like, seeing them loosen up.
And um...
Loosen up and just like, you know.
Being super fun.
And just fucking around.
I love vibes like that.
I like those types of vibes.
So I'm happy to...
To have those vibes playing the tournament.
Um...
And we traded like a pub.
I mean, we did pretty well for trading like a pub.
So that's...
Fuck yeah!
Also...
There's a little fucking tidbit.
Like Kuno was apparently gonna be in this tournament.
Um...
But then I told him, cause he wanted me as a third.
And I was like, bro...
You need a pro player.
Or you're not gonna have a good time.
And he was like, what?
And I was like, bro, this tournament is not for fun.
Like...
And he was like...
And I think his team dropped out cause they saw the team roster.
And they're like, yeah, no.
And then his team was like, yeah, we're not playing this.
Like...
I was like, bro, I'm captain.
And I'm like...
I'm picking up pro players because...
Because like...
Because it's like...
The roster seems so fucking sweaty.
And then he dropped out.
Cause he was like...
Cause I was like, bro, there's some players in there that are going to fucking LAN.
Like actually going to LAN.
Realize...
Yeah, he almost got...
He almost played.
And I was like, bro, no.
No, you're not going to have fun.
I swear to God.
Like if you bump into any of these teams, you're not going to have fun.
So...
So that...
So like...
I saved him there.
Cause I told him like...
I'm not...
Get a pro player, bro.
Don't get like a random person for your third.
Cause I don't remember who his first was.
But the first player was not like pro.
But I was like, bro, get a pro player.
Like it's not going to...
You're going to need it.
You're going to be running away.
You're going to be fucking fodder.
You're going to be fodder for these people, bro.
You got to get a pro.
You scared him off.
I had to.
I didn't want him to be miserable.
Um...
I didn't want him to be miserable playing.
Cause that's not the fun part.
When you die early, it's not fun.
Like we died early twice.
And we had to like sit there.
Like we had to sit there.
Cause we fought.
It's just unlucky.
The two teams we...
Um...
The two teams we fought...
Fought was like...
Um...
We fought were like...
The pro teams too.
Like I think like...
When we died early...
Both the teams we fought were the pro teams.
So like it was very...
It was very scary.
Um...
So yeah, but we got them.
We took them out.
The moment we took out Skip, we did it for everybody.
I think if we knew...
I think if we knew that there wasn't going to be a last game...
I think we would have definitely played a lot more safe.
I just went in thinking we have another game.
I...
But that's fine.
We still did really well.
Anyway guys, we got Skippity.
We're the people's champion.
We literally got Skippity out for everybody.
Anyway, I'm going to head off now.
I am going to rest up.
My voice is dying and um...
I need to...
I need to take my meds for real.
And I'll see you guys next time everybody.
I hope you guys have fun.
As always everybody...
stay hydrated, posture checked.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
You stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I really want to play with this team again.
When we're all feeling a lot better.
They were really fun to play with.
So I'm super down to play with Effect and Unlucky again.
For like a run back.
When we're all healthy.
And like...
When we're all healthy and not fucked up.
When we're all feeling more freaky.
But yeah, I hope we can play again.
I hope there's another tournament...
and we can get them in.
But yeah, I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!